yes I have no I have no idea what's what
we're doing um just launch there's no
we're live now we're live uh people can
watch it Michael Mouse sitting right
next to me so let me let me just start
saying uh no verdict tonight in the car
writtenhouse trial I see people
commenting like they thought they're
doing this big show because they thought
the verdict was going to come in and
they're gonna break no no no no no no no
he's shaking said
um here's what happened let me tell you
the story so we're coming down to Austin
and we're trying to find good people in
Austin to talk to and Blair white hi so
we were like we got oh Lydia just ran
out the door uh okay well we'll we'll
show Blair white Joe Rogan is in town
and we have the Michael malice and Luke
radowski and Tim Poole well so so here's
what Evan um we asked Blair to come on
the show uh because we're we love Blair
and then uh Alex was like hey are you
guys gonna have am I coming on at all
and we were like
you know be really cool if you came out
with Blair white but we got to make sure
Blair's cool with it of course I was I
was totally down and then it kept
escalate and then it was Michael so then
someone leaked it to Michael and he was
like you're having me on that show right
yeah and I was like yeah yeah I like how
he works and we're all asking to come on
of course we want to come on Tim you're
great but then it's like I'm thinking
I'm like oh oh man this is this is huge
like what are we gonna do and so and
then Joe Rogan calls well hold on hold
on
wait let him tell his story we had Drew
Hernandez here who's sitting right here
I don't know what camera works for Drew
because we know Lydia how do I switch
this he's got a job to do Lydia we are
all here and it's amazing okay get to
work woman it's for me oh I don't want
to throw it across all this stuff
I want to pass they're disorganized mess
thank you okay hold on I warned everyone
this would be a cacophony
Drew is here and we were I was like Drew
Drew like if the verdict comes in we oh
it's Joe Rogan there you go
what up bro
you're now podcasting out of an RV
brother how the mighty have fallen
ladies and gentlemen
look at that beautiful
right yeah the show is about to begin
yeah we got Alex Jones Joe Rogan Tim
pool Michael malice Drew Hernandez who
knows this is this is it right now this
is regular internet I am still breaking
the internet everyone needs to share
this link now
A dog bit me
[Music]
[Music]
we have a limited time with Lord Rogan
let's see what he has to say oh
well so so uh Drew is here yes and we
were talking like Drew if the verdict
comes down the Rittenhouse case he's an
eyewitness he filmed it I was like we
can you stick around to come on the show
and uh it's not the whole thing saw the
whole thing he was he testified in the
trial it was totally different than the
video right
what part just kidding no it wasn't yeah
yeah yeah yeah
when you see people like Anna kasparian
saying I thought I
thought it was it was a totally
different thing the footage has been out
for like the entire time but everybody
thought it was a totally different thing
because they would also censor the
footage you couldn't yeah because the
corporate press is the enemy of the
people did you see how MSNBC would not
show the defense responses only right
yeah only the prosecution well so so we
were like Drew stick around and then
when this show just became whatever
whatever the hell is going on everyone
was like Tim did you ask Joe to come on
and I was like oh Joe's he's got a show
he's busy guy and I was like well Hey
Joe you want to break the internet you
know Michael's breaking the internet
[ __ ] I'm just showing up at your weird
trailer remember remember when I told
you though I was gonna get a van this
it's awesome it really is
I love the fact you have a screen it's
brilliant right I love it I want it this
is amazing and I like it the screen that
oh so you can't see it on camera but the
screen we have for everyone to watch the
news like to see the news articles you
pull up Rises up from the dress up
that's very fancy
that's right so Joe Rogan in the house
Alex Jones ladies and gentlemen right
about basically everything finally it's
all coming down the truth is coming out
so Thomas Jefferson was in the
Illuminati a bunch of demons Joe Rogan
is the 46th president of the United
States sulfur
my God people are just giving us money
oh God that's how it works dude I'm I'm
already so it's getting it's hot in here
listen it's kind of exciting I like it
let Joe talk isn't it kind of exciting
though like obviously the world has gone
completely into chaos yes it's
integrated like we are in this weird
position where the mainstream media is
almost universally accepted as at least
being mostly full of [ __ ] or partly full
of [ __ ] totally full of crap some let's
the most the most optimistic person says
well they lie sometimes right that was
never the case with Walter Cronkite
exactly who are also lied all the time
all the time when people didn't realize
it they lie like a crackhead hitting on
a crack rock Alex every word they say is
a lie including and in the
no we've reached new levels of being
able to expose them they relied us into
the Spanish war in Cuba 100 years ago
nothing's changed that's the truth right
Rosebud yes yeah yeah Gulf of Tonkin
operation it's always been live I've
always been live destruction right this
is the way they do business the New York
Times refused to report that Germany was
targeting Jews exactly because that
would be buying into identity politics
at the time because Jews were white and
that's what Hitler said Jews weren't
White and the government knew about it
and they covered it up including the
railroads which they could have stopped
but they decided not to there's a book
called Hold on let me just make one
point there's a book called buried by
the times look it up yep and this was
how they covered it up because they
didn't want to buy into what Hitler was
saying how are we how like how is it now
different you know if they've been I
think they've been lying the whole time
yeah but how are we now figuring it out
right well I'll tell you what's about to
happen they're devaluing the currency on
purpose to crash all the world of
currencies and bring out the great reset
that's not what we're talking about Alex
no this is the build back better agenda
malice no you're asking malice
no why it's more obvious when a guy
starts talking you don't talk over them
yes that's how we do we have Alex do we
have a conch yes
it's the great reset
resetwars.com the point is is this the
great reset and they're plunging the
world economy on By Design to
consolidate control and kill all the
major currencies that's why there's
inflation that's why there's supply
chain breakdowns I'm just telling you
tomorrow's news today there is a global
destruction of the supply chain in the
world currencies to bring in a new world
currency based on the vaccine passport
the issue what they were asking is you
know has it has the corporate press
gotten worse and my point is we have
more mechanisms to expose their
depravity and malfeasance in real time
for example if this had been 20 years
ago they would have been a position not
to let this calibrating House video ever
anyone would ever see it now if you have
some kind of hacked journalist with his
cameraman one's wearing a mask one's not
everyone's got a phone and all it takes
is one person to film it put on Twitter
or Facebook and then immediately
everyone can see it in real time Michael
I totally agree with you I just sent you
a text message with a meme it's an
amazing meme with Alex you gotta look at
this it's one of my favorite memes it's
like it's a you are here meme it's all
the [ __ ] that Alex has predicted that's
come true right now let me read it let
me read it can you get it can you get it
on your screen yeah through a text
message you [ __ ] primitive tweet it
tweet it out post it on Instagram
well they'll pull it up wait wait wait
wait I can Facebook it too can I oh yeah
let me just say this nicely everybody's
right I I'm obnoxious and I'm horrible
and I apologize no that's not what the
mean Michael you're right well thank you
sir I'll send you the meme I know I'm
saying malice is trying to talk about
how the establishment meeting is dead
I'm talking about how the
establishment's hitting us economically
so he's making a legitimate point I'm
making a separate point about yeah the
the the progenitor of the problems we
have yeah I think you guys are both true
there is a global Awakening but there's
also a drastic escalation when it comes
to the great reset the build back better
agenda what Clash Schwab is having wet
dreams about when it comes to enslaving
humanity making people live odds making
people eat bugs having them as Little
Pages
that's because they're not going down
without a fight once the mask is off you
better get whatever but we win the fight
or quicker we know who they are
make that larger make that Meme larger
look at that [ __ ] your TV's buying a new
check Bohemian Elite cabal of sex
traffickers check they're turning the
frogs gay yeah
right yeah uh Bohemian Grove check
silver iodine
uh rich people using baby blood I'm not
that's true no it's happening down in
Mexico right now is it really yes it is
people are are doing that yep you are
here human monkey chimeras which he
predicted a long time ago where's that
where's that where's that you're saying
the elves aren't real that's no that's
next well the elves of course they're
real they're coming next what is silver
iodide that's like some [ __ ] that kills
diseases yeah it's true yeah it's
essentially true but also now let me let
me let makes your skin blue but I'll
point something out I'll point something
about this meme the TV spying on you
Alex you were pointing these things out
because they were happening the turning
the frog is gay that was atrazine I
believe that's a pesticide right and
that was messing with the endocrine
systems of frogs which was causing weird
deformities I was just covering a
burglary study yeah but it was more
turning than changing their gender and
it wasn't making them but here's the
deal I'll be here for five hours Joe's
got to go to his show then why are you
yelling
that's how he talked normally you have a
microphone
I'm sorry I am the Alex wisp you should
see him in church
[Laughter]
Joe's nice to say nice things about me
but Joe's also predicted a lot of stuff
that came true what did I predict
you pretty okay oh my God have you
watched your earlier comedy I don't
think oh probably not maybe okay I
remember in like 1999 I just met Joe
before like gone to dinner with him and
like this producer I know and then I'll
go to see him at the Cap City comedy
club now defunct and he goes up and he
goes let me tell you what's going to
kill the corporate media in Hollywood
and everybody it's gonna be the internet
it was the first guy I heard say that
100 he goes there's no way they can
compete with energy this whole freaking
rant and it was all true and then he
went on to say but the sucky part about
technology is is they claim me all these
Jetson suits and jet packs and all this
radical stuff but instead your cell
phone craps out when you're in behind a
bush yeah right the problem like this is
like uh you ever see that movie
Talladega Nights where he says like he
ain't first you laughed yeah he's like I
was high when I said that same answer
you know my problem I feel like
corporate media is no longer NBC ABC now
it's Google and of course Facebook it's
all in a way it's a lot worse Facebook
is worse than it is
essential lives it needs to be
decentralized yes sir there needs to be
decentralized uh open communication
where people need to find out what the
[ __ ] is really going on we're finding
that through all these corporate Co all
these like internet companies whether
it's Google or whether it's Facebook or
Instagram if they can just censor you
based on ideology then you don't have
freedom of speech because they're the
primary means that people communicate so
until we accept that there's some sort
of utility it's not as simple as it's a
private company when it's literally one
of the main two or three ways that human
beings share ideas across the planet
[ __ ] Earth it's bigger than just a
company and and I don't know what the
solution to that is but we have to have
that conversation
they're abusing their power right
because the way it it censors is always
in favor of the left and the people on
the left think that's a good idea but
eventually you can't be left enough it's
just gonna keep going it's gonna it's a
machine it's Pac-Man yeah wait wait wait
wait I gotta ask Joe
um so uh a couple years ago you had Jack
Dorsey on your show
you got a bunch of dislikes on the video
we ended up talking you end up inviting
me out and I don't know destroyed it
well I thought about that I wanted to
ask you like how do you feel your
opinion has changed since before we did
that show and did you wear it today well
there's a lot of things have opened my
eyes like slowly but surely like seeing
examples of people censored and some of
them that don't make any sense at all
like one of the one of the best ones was
Brett Weinstein and his whole um this
whole Unity party yeah that when when
that got censored I was like okay you
guys banned an account for no reason
because you thought that that account
which is by a bunch of influential
influential uh intellectuals was going
to somehow another take votes away from
what you thought the party that should
win and so you just banned the account
so now you're making like these
ideological choices about free speech so
you're saying your free speech is not as
important as the result that I want and
so you're gonna ban people and when I
saw that I was like this is wild this is
[ __ ] wild and then I talked to a lot
of people that were the Second Amendment
advocates they were saying before the
election they were going back into their
Instagrams and their Facebooks and
finding posts from eight nine years ago
and and banning them for those posts
that they were going deep yeah they were
doing that just specifically because
they didn't want people influencing the
vote in any way a thousand here a
hundred there like if they could just
Chip Away through all these different
angles and make examples just briefly
look at that imagine it's one thing for
a an Orthodoxy to take over and make you
comply but to punish you before it took
over is thought crime
before I mean this is mind control this
is this is this is like in science
fiction this was never dreamed of where
you're punished for behavior before the
new Orthodoxy comes in so you don't just
submit in the current state you're going
to pay for not adopting it before it was
the news I got to correct you this isn't
science fiction this is what they did in
the Soviet Union where if you're on the
wrong side before Stalin took over you
were executed with your family but this
has historical presence my family was
literally tortured in Poland for daring
to question in the government or not
having the proper paperwork when during
a random passport check no no no no no I
know Luke I know Pirates do that
it's retroactive enforcement yes
retroactive they cut his [ __ ] nose in
Chinatown let me let me let me let me I
want to counter this though because we
were we were actually heading in a
direction in this conversation we were
talking about how we're actually
starting to realize how deceptive the
media is and then I pointed it over to
Drew because these same tools are what
allowed you know Drew to be on the
ground exactly right now uh uh during
the Kenosha incident film it and then be
a winner us the media could have
absolutely shut it down you've heard it
you'd see a newspaper article and it
would say white supremacists crosses
state lines with gun and that's the only
thing you'd know and they tried it drew
Richie Jorge Ventura Elijah they broke
down Paradise were down there and then
to watch the prosecutor try to go oh
you're a right winger you're evil it's
like it's footage it's raw like Joe said
oh and then they saw the raw footage
once you see that it's game you
literally tried to say that my footage
was slanted in a certain way and I
responded and I said well yes it's BLM
and antifa are literally rioting in the
footage what people need to understand
is this propaganda is so dangerous not
because they're just telling lies but
they're attempting to control the
narrative which is an attempt to control
your mind and that's what's dangerous
whether you're Republican or a Democrat
that should seriously concern you
because this is what they do to control
the minds of millions of people and it's
allowed on a daily basis and it's like
why don't it's encouraging why don't
people take issue with this that people
are trying to control your mind because
on a daily basis of the average man and
would rather be safe than be free we're
taught since kids to defer that expert
and one of the reasons
one of the reasons they always talk
about follow the experts it's not just
with uh um covid it's also with this am
I going to look at the footage and draw
my own conclusion or am I going to
listen to the prosecutor
sad because I don't know any Progressive
I know a lot of progressives and not one
of them knows that one of the victims of
Kyle was a pedophile they all think it
was an innocent black BLM who raped the
kid it's not like he had to try
attraction five kids okay five kids and
he was an underage boy during this you
know
so it's it messes with people so badly I
know so many people that have no
information about the case but have an
opinion completely made up wasn't the
other guy didn't he get all charges
dismissed on previous six days before
yeah six days before he had a DUI charge
drop but he was a career criminal I mean
he went down for domestic abuse prowling
trespassing two DUIs felony burglary two
counts of caring a firearm while
intoxicated this is the culture yeah
yeah we're in a culture
tell us
how does the Kool-Aid shut up
this information is not based on reality
this is a left-wing cult and they're
they're pumping stuff out and then
they're confirming this belief they're
they're all getting together and they're
ignoring contrary evidence yes they're
ignoring any narrative that challenges
their belief about what happened and
they're not looking at it realistically
they're only looking at like you would
look at it if you're in a [ __ ] cult
sounds like a weird left it well cult is
a religion that's just like it's just
older now I said about it well the cult
doesn't let you ask questions Joe go
ahead well a cult is made by a guy and
that guy knows it's a cult and a
religion that guy's dead that's the
difference like religions are just Cults
that last longer some of them prove to
be worthwhile put like social and
economic and and even uh moral
structures like they actually benefit
Society like some some Cults they're
based on rituals or things that people
learned and they realize this is a
better way to live their life and but
some of them are just based on the
present moment of gathering the most
amount of whether it is uh influence or
finances or what what power whatever the
[ __ ] it is that's what this is you know
what I totally agree so let me ask the
next question I really want to hear what
you ever say how what is the period
we're in now because it seems like it's
coming to an end this is Kali Yuga man
this is this is some weird [ __ ] that was
predicted by the bhagavad-gita this is
this is like this wrong Battle of the
Gods Ragnarok tell me this is what
happens in cultures like they go through
these like these pitches these ups and
downs and it's almost inevitable like
it's almost impossible for us with our
human reward systems that are based on
like animal emotions and biology to mag
to manage millions and millions and
millions of people all on one continent
with money and the economy and the
[ __ ] environment it's almost
impossible to do so it almost always
slides into authoritarianism and the
best way it slides into authoritarianism
is control the narrative yeah you've got
to leave keep going brother so you say
it's almost impossible how would you say
we can do it mushrooms beautifully
mushrooms
we need mushrooms to realize we're all
in this thing together we can instead of
competing with each other just do your
best and give everybody hugs so let's
expand on that right don't agree a lot
of hallucinogens why do hallucinus taken
properly create such peace why are they
because they eliminate the ego and the
ego's responsible for most of the
conflict most the conflict is instead of
think I gotta get this guy back just
relax everybody relax everybody like
look at this like what does everybody
want in terms of like you forgave me
three years ago when I was being a
everybody and it was so much better
forgive everybody listen it's amazing
what does everybody want this life you
want good friends you want to be safe
you want your your children to go to
good schools you want your loved ones to
be protected you want people to get by
and have a good life for as long as they
possibly can that's what everybody wants
but you think that other people are
trying to stop you from having that
other people trying to stop you from
having that as a few sociopaths that
want to gather it all up to themselves
but but Joe I I've had this conversation
with Ian a whole lot because Ian's the
voice on our show who's always telling
us to stop being so dark and try and
bring people together but you look at
the prosecutor in in the writtenhouse
case he's a demon over overwhelmed like
lying you see the judge say that child's
life grave constitutional violation I
think that's been going on forever
finally we have the internet correct
thank you yeah now now we can see it for
whatever and now we can see and now
conservatives are realizing you know the
local conservative line about like oh if
you haven't done anything wrong don't
worry about getting arrested you'll be
fine I know but conserva is now
realizing wait a minute when the
government the eye of Sauron has you in
your in their sights they're gonna do
whatever they can I've been experiencing
that where like they just lie about it
what are you just saying about not
interrupting
I was just just the one point is people
a lot of malice for me I don't have a
lot of love for you start over I'm not
going to start over I'm just going to
say my one sentence which is conservice
now realizing when the government which
is the eye of Sauron has it you in their
sights they're gonna do whatever they
can to break you and this is something
that disproportionately hurts poor
people and the left has been arguing
about that for a long time and they were
right yeah yeah that's inarguable right
yes
well there's something to say about
what's happening right now some people
have called it the fourth turning you
could feel it it's it's energetic you
know something's happening you see the
Titanic you see the iceberg you're like
holy cow the ship is heading somewhere
but at the end of the day we could still
decide where it goes and I think to
Joe's Point mushrooms decentralization
are ways to start the conversation but
uh I think we should focus on that as
well because I think that's the true
kind of opening that we should be really
examining and looking into because there
is something to talk about with so much
power and influence here we could do
something incredible here I don't know
about mushrooms but that NAD stuff was
legit nicotine
nucleotide can we talk about DMT while
Joe's here because he's giving me DMT
next week I am or should I not say that
no no we were thinking about it going
down to South America for a religious
retreat perhaps oh I'm so in
yeah well I take DMT everything
we all take we all take DMT when we
sleep that's what I was saying
I've heard you got to do a dieta which
is a 10-day fast where you basically
stop only stop all that hippie [ __ ]
put your [ __ ] Woody beads aside
it's the same thing it's
dimethyltryptamine look it's good to
have an empty stomach yeah but listen
what you really need to do is just relax
and let it happen have you taken Aya no
I've only taken DMV we got to do
Ayahuasca I've taken I don't know how to
do [ __ ] with you but you filthy hippie
get a haircut we need to all of a sudden
I'm at his house like confused when do I
throw up no it's like all these
psychedelic drugs the big thing is just
letting go that's the the biggest
problem that people have let yourself go
like Elvis says yeah it's hard to just
not fight it yeah well that's one of the
biggest lessons when you do delve into
psychedelics is not to take yourself too
seriously let things go let love and the
positive energies kind of flow in a
direction where you're not trying to
control everything thing when you're
trying to control everything that's when
things get nasty and disgusting whether
in relationships whether in government
whether religion anytime you try to
force something out to someone [ __ ] gets
bad it gets distressed while we've got
Joe here let me just ask this one
question of Joe and I want to hear some
Tim and everybody here but this is my
real question after all the suppression
of free speech we've seen the last 20
months and after all the attacks on
medical experts that were pointing
certain things out that's now all been
proven right
I mean I what does the power structure
do now that it's committed sepiku
suicide I'm really concerned no no no no
no don't be don't be naive it has not
committed suicide most people still
believe the news is accurate most people
still believe I took horse dewormer most
people still believe like some of the
dumbest ideas because most people are
casual observers of information so
you're saying I'm blinded by the fact
that I'm I'm here it's your job you're
you're like a guy who's like a tennis
analyst that thinks that everybody knows
who Roger Federer is most people have no
[ __ ] idea right it's like the the
amount of people that actually pay
attention to all this so I'm blinded by
the fact that I'm informed yeah you're
very informed you're always on it but
what's gonna happen or uninformed
because they're busy all day they have
jobs and they have kids they have a
mortgage and they [ __ ] go bowling or
whatever they like to do they don't have
the time whatever the normies do they
watch football they don't have time to
be paying attention to all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] so instead of the normalcy bias I
have kind of an awake so what do we do
listen I was I was arguing with someone
about the Rittenhouse trial right now A
friend of mine who's on the left who
said I don't understand how you're
defending this kid and when I said like
a q feed a a few key details about the
case they said I didn't hear that and
then they responded to be honest I was
kind of just listening in the background
while I was yeah yeah yeah it's all
crazy right like should he have just
showed up with an AR-15 with his protest
like why is he there like why he's 17
year old kid with a [ __ ] money
then you learned that his family had a
store there right yeah
his dad had a business in his business
his dad his grandma his cousins he
worked there his best friend that was
his hometown his mom had left but how
Wild are these [ __ ] people this is
like wild and wonderful Whites of West
Virginia they said Son load up your
AR-15 who want to drive into the protest
you're 17 like to take a 17 year old kid
to the middle of a [ __ ] protest with
a loaded wasn't a protest it was a riot
okay let's say it's a riot but before it
happened it was a surprise
is anybody here besides me and Alex have
children negative when you have kids the
last thing you want to tell your 17 year
olds hey son we're gonna take you down
to that Riot yeah my son's bigger than
me
that's wild [ __ ] like I'm not I'm just
not a judgment call I'm saying it's a
very unusual move wait my uncle drive
your 17 year old kid across the state no
no I I mean I like renting the house but
they're a little weird wait wait wait
wait wait
mind thing is too much 31 miles yeah but
it's still State Line right I guess
hold on here's why it's much do you know
the law there's a law when it comes to
like Firearms when it comes to like you
do it's like he didn't bring a gun
across okay but state lines are real
it's a real thing like if you live in
one place and you go to another place
specifically for this reason the
prosecutors or the lawmakers or
whoever's going to look at it very
differently just because you're crossing
a state line that's just fact it's like
you're Invaders that being said if you
do something inside of Kansas that's
inside of Kansas if you decide to cross
over into another place it becomes a
different thing right being said there
are people who live in places like
Buffalo and Detroit who and Mexico who
have enhanced IDs who are able to go
back and forth as if it's is that what
he had well he lived like a mile from
the board and Kenosha was it's the
suburb but but what a lot of people are
missing is he went across the border and
then got a gun right right he didn't
cross the border with the gun right
correct so he went across the border and
then he got it also he's not even 18.
it's it's kind of wild like if you think
about an actual 17 year old boy they're
boys he's more than man than any of
those police officers he did a very good
you know son of a [ __ ] cut nose but at
the same time Nicholson in Chinatown
they cut his nose but but not too much
[ __ ] but but Joe you gotta understand
during that summer police officers stood
back police officers stand down don't do
anything oh for sure and it's not a
cleaning and it's not and I don't think
it's not the best case to to argue but I
think this is the kind of pivotal point
that a lot of people especially the
corporate media are focusing on because
this is the argument that they want to
make to disarm well I'll go back to
they're not showing the defense
arguments on a lot of TV channels that
that discredits him right there but let
me ask Joe before he's got to go here
he's got to go to comedy show tonight
let me ask Joe his his view shifting
gears on the political correct War but
hold on hold on keep talking about this
because that's an important thing to
like expand on what we're talking about
here like this is here's the problem
here's the big problem why did he have
to do that he was coming hold on why did
he have to do that why did no no no no
no what what compelled him to do that I
have an anarchy because there was chaos
in the Stream because they were allowing
it to happen correct the reason why
people were willing to tell their kid
hey this is a good idea to get your
[ __ ] loaded gun and we're gonna like
it's because civilizations collapse
right they finally go oh [ __ ] this
wasn't Anarchy this was state-funded
mainstream media promoted chaos
was literally bailing them out
people aren't getting like detailed
instructions on exactly what to do
they're antifa people right they're wild
[ __ ] that have criminal records
pedophiles
who's giving them organizations whatever
the cell is so Joe what happens when
he's found not guilty I predict but when
they're telling him do you think
someone's telling him to attack this kid
no hold on hold on yeah
hold on I can actually answer this I
spent his whole life so there's
something important a lot of
conservatives understand about these
these wealthy billionaires who fund
these nonprofits there will be 2 two
people from an organization that is
funded they come down to events and they
know there's a lot of angry people who
have no idea they don't they don't say
to them hey go attack that kid they just
say things like if anyone tries to stop
them don't let them respect the
diversity of tactics it's a very common
phrase it means if someone is committing
acts of violence let them do it that's
bad and they have strategies they call
themselves often facilitators they will
come down to a riot and then guide the
the destruction in certain ways and try
and take that that the violence and use
it we got secret antifa documents five
years ago where they even in Democrat
areas or working with the police the
government and they have targets they're
going to burn things they're going to
hit it's all not only yeah but there's
been in some ways it's a rhetorical
question what I'm saying is why did he
have to do that wait we had to do that
because everything was falling right no
but I had to elaborate yes sir I had
Robert Burns on my show this week he
worked for the defense team and my
understanding according to Robert is uh
the people who ran that car dealership
called Kyle and several several other
people because that car dealership had
been hit night after night so they were
specifically called in to defend this
location there's four locations and they
circled around which people are allowed
to defend their property yes of course
especially when the police just saying
we refuse to do anything so Joe to
answer you know what you're trying to
forget how bad summer of 2020 was like I
lived in the middle of Hollywood when it
was all at its peak and I had to
evacuate my home and hide in the woods
and stay there for like two weeks until
it was somewhat safe to go back yeah I'm
surprised there wasn't more of that
there wasn't more car rental three dozen
people died I mean you know you left
that like how many crime where he does
uh three dozen listen I showed up on
night one in Kenosha right and right
when I showed up on the scene they
already had dumpster trucks on fire yeah
the reason why I decided to take an Uber
from Chicago all the way to Kenosha was
because on Twitter they were already
taking bricks to police officers heads
and knocking them unconscious so there
was literally nothing peaceful it was
never a peaceful protest from night one
no the mainstream media doesn't want to
talk about this a mostly fiery peaceful
protest right but it was listen I always
say this Kenosha from night one was
obviously a riot but it was a crime
scene for three days straight and here's
why I say this on the third night when I
returned back to Kenosha I was talking
to some of the people on the ground some
of people that had their businesses
burned down to the ground when you were
walking down the street people had their
Windows boarded up they were riding
things like children live here you want
to know why they were writing that
because there was a threat to the
community there was an obvious threat to
the community we're gonna die Alex
people thought that they were gonna die
in Kenosha because of violent acts that
were being committed by these criminals
and they're trying to paint this picture
that they were were peaceful protesters
at no point was Kenosha a peaceful
protest on night one night two or night
three and Joseph Rosenbaum was violent
at night four after after Kyle did his
duty they brought the National Guard
abolish the police yes of course Joe you
were saying it's all rhetorical what's
the answer then I don't have an answer
bro
come on man
no no I do love I do love the constant
like Joe tell us he ain't gonna be here
the whole time I mean yeah I know but
silly Joe just fix the world already all
right what are you doing come on all
right we're waiting here we're trying to
guide this thing do everything what was
the question you know we we you know
Blair's right we we forget what the [ __ ]
it was like it was terrifying it was
terrifying the world was falling apart
there was cop cars lit on fire all
throughout Hollywood they were they were
calling a curfew in uh Beverly Hills at
like 4 P.M or some [ __ ] but you know
what people watching windows and
stealing Santa Monica and they were
allowing it they were letting it burn
out they so people had this feeling that
no one was going to protect anyone
correct like it's when you look at the
way things stand today we have much more
assembles of Law and Order but when you
go back to those George Floyd protests
it was Anarchy it was legitimate chaos
and I don't think people have long
memories they're very short memories
you're talking about but the cop cars
actually I know someone who rents out a
ton of prop cop cars for movies in LA
and some of those were fake like on
Melrose which is weird I don't know why
take cop cars yeah they were probably
well let me tell you I don't know why
they were shooting and burning and
robbing in Austin and deaths I was
driving through and Andrew was backing
on my windows so there was stuff going
down there yeah yeah I don't know if
those were fake cars but I know that's a
fun thing to say no no those cop cars
weren't even real bro they were made by
a billion dollars of property laws they
were prop cars like Alec Baldwin's prop
gun well the scariest thing the scariest
thing was like looking at New York City
when they were smashing windows and that
really like uh whatever that art area is
Soho yeah they were stealing things
right out of these buildings and the
cops were literally standing on the
corner watching that happen like that is
mad I remember watching that on Fox news
they were literally this was this was I
I wouldn't say this is anarchy because
if he had Anarchy we would have peaceful
harmonious trade of capital Amen brother
and
um
what we had is is government funded
orchestrated chaos by the top
institutions and powerhouses in this
world saying I want this to happen I
will incentivize it I will spread
propaganda I will put fuel on the fire
guaranteeing that this violence explodes
I wanted people to ride
I'm not trying to change subjects
because the writtenhouse thing's huge
and Anarchy's all what about Joe Biden
because you early on said he's you know
a year before he got in but he said it
it wasn't anything let me ask you then
what that's my next question everybody
here go around the round table what is
the prediction because now they're in
the Washington Post New York Times
saying Joe Biden's got to go Kamala
Harris Pete Buddha judge what happens to
Joe well if you heard the things that
like they're trying to figure out
whether like is it Jill Biden was asking
whether did you read those things Jill
Biden was asking whether or not they can
get rid of Kamala yeah I don't know
really oh yeah I don't know that's true
I just read it no no that was even that
was I was watching it was like on MSNBC
one before I came on
today at the end of the day like they've
got to find someone who could fill Joe
Biden's shoes but if they decided to
have Pete butterjudge LeapFrog over
Kamala Harris it's gonna be wild because
even like the hardcore lefties are gonna
abandon each other well like they're
good it's going to get really wild
because the people that wanted her in
there because of identity politics and
now have a point of argument even
whether or not they think she was good
or not they think that she got in they
wanted her in for whatever specific
reasons and now she's in and you're
gonna have this guy LeapFrog over her if
that happens if they think the only way
they can win in 2024 is people to judge
we're gonna have wild and see I am
kissing Joseph he's really politically
smarter this 20 years ago but he's doing
it now exactly they're clearly
pre-positioning Buddha judge to take
over it's all over the freaking noise
it's a trial balloon because her
approval ratings are 28 right uh
everyone in Washington hates her Gavin
Newsom hates circus she took the
California uh position for the
presidency away from him wow so he hates
her of course he hates her because she's
because you hear me talking [ __ ] I'm not
that way they cut your nose [ __ ]
that's fake that's a false flag hey
careful Alex you don't want to get in
trouble with that
I think they're gonna take Michelle
Obama or Oprah 2013.
they're openly saying everywhere we've
got to replace Biden now and that's
everywhere so I'm asking what are they
planning how that Satchel Page thing was
over the top people like check check
please what was that this is the Negro
thing well so the Negro Leagues yeah he
goes there's no he's the number one I
won't even say it he's the best in the
world yeah did you see though when the
when the judge and I keep throwing back
to right now's case the judge said I
hope the Asian food's not on the Long
Beach port and they were like what a
racist that's when Joe Biden comes out
and said you know took the heat off him
it must be 100 clean here right on this
whole thing the point is he's
degenerating he's falling it's clearly
something's wrong so you can't wait much
it's not it's not fair it's not it's
like to judge him like in comparison to
like judging Obama when he was in office
or judging even Trump when he was on
it's not fair he's got a problem there's
something wrong with him right it's not
as simple as I don't like the things
stands for or the special interest
groups that have got him into power I
don't like his politics that's not
what's going on here this is like this
is a man who's compromised something's
wrong and he's deteriorating and either
we admit that and we all admit we all
know it or we don't admit it so we don't
admit it then China just starts [ __ ]
filling up Facebook with a bunch of fake
Pages we have chaos constantly you know
I mean this that's part of what's going
on like with the the conversations that
people are having online yeah nobody
respects us because of him right and it
is it's insane he's the first president
who's literally shitty wow foreign
what's happening you know it's like
we're we're in the cult and if you're in
the cult you have to pretend that the
cult Leader's okay you know the cult
Leader's not okay in fact have you seen
all the pointers that are opening their
mouths more and more people going hey we
gotta do something and be like okay okay
okay so they're coming out of this
[ __ ] fog and they're going what about
that people the ditch guy who's playing
three months off for his [ __ ] kid
like that's okay people have short
memories let's get them back in here
what about the meme I sent you today of
like the Hollywood guys going he's a
rock star he's punk rock I mean there's
still some are still trying oh that's
Joe Biden yeah
does have intelligence agency
connections so he he was tried to be as
the kind of prop guy they did try to
push him so I wouldn't be surprised if
they try to push him again but again the
mainstream media let's admit this
corporate media put in Biden the
corporate media will be putting in the
next president of the United States
they're definitely gonna try AI but the
problem is they don't have the clear
like a person that stands I go oh like
on the right if Trump wasn't around
you'll get Ron DeSantis to go that's the
guy yeah he's
reasonable yeah
he's strong he's reasonable he's calm
he's made great judgment choices during
this pandemic with Florida they've
turned out to be like although
controversial ultimately you go good to
like the end result good choices
like business in terms of like real
estate all these different things that
didn't deteriorate like they did in
these other countries where they kept
the same mortality rate you look at
Florida's business Florida's business
did very well in comparison to like
California but California took a big hit
the restaurants and even though they
have the same sort of mortality rate
when you adjust for age Florida did
better and then when you look at
business Florida did way back California
has doubled the cases of Florida right
now but but here's the next question
I didn't get like money because I
supported Trump I didn't think Trump was
perfect I thought that he was you got
Pokemon dollars right exactly I thought
it was more of a populist better than
you know what we were being offered uh
and so with Hillary Clinton who I know
is evil but but now I almost seek Trump
is destructive because he becomes the
opposition to the Democrats but he's got
his own issues I want to be populist not
left or Not Right But Americans coming
together and saying no to Joe Biden no
the Democratic party that lied about
Russia gate and all of it I don't think
Trump's a bad guy but I want to be clear
at the end of the day he went along with
warp speed he went along with the
experimental shot and he's pig-headed
and he won't admit he was wrong so I'm
not going to criticize Biden and Pfizer
for this and fauci and then give Trump a
pass and with Trump's base I go to these
big events with five ten twenty thousand
people they're really upset and then
Trump is so pigh-headed that he is still
going along with well the vaccine
we have to say always talk to your
doctor about what's right for you don't
take advice from people on the internet
talk to your doctor if you're feeling
unwell and you want to get advice on
what you should do to treat you
take your booster shot reset wars.com
now they're doing uh this Show's
outrageous New York has announced
we're in a trailer on the side of the
road England is announcing if you don't
have the boosters you're going to be
launching your house just like Austria
and Australia and Francis but oh but
let's not talk about it because they'll
ban us on there you're right I want
hundreds of shots and I think I find I
think Trump's wonderful then Alex Jones
I'm sick of [ __ ] Trump right when I'm
sick of all these [ __ ] people why
haven't you guys gotten him drunk yet
we can't do that that's bad you haven't
even thought but no listen listen listen
there's a big difference between
someone's private medical decisions the
way I see it is I I went to the doctor
you went to the doctor and they gave us
specific medical advice Joe let me tell
you when when I when I talk to the
doctor I actually asked them I said I
don't want Ivermectin or z-pack I said
the monoclonal antibodies fix me up just
right good and the doctor said no I want
you to finish what you've been
prescribed and I said do I do I really
have to and they said yes because if it
comes back this is what we're
prescribing you and so I was actually
like kind of critical and the well the
media still lies about it the point is
if you go to your doctor and you figure
out whatever you want I don't care
that's fine do what you want to do if
you know a lot of people have asked me
like would you get the vaccine now well
I got regeneron the monoclonal so I
can't and it provides eight months of
protection or whatever that's what
they're saying the point is mandating by
government a medical procedure for you
to buy lunch is [ __ ] insane it is why
are you swearing on the shower it's over
but but if someone if like I I've got
we've had so many people on the show who
are like uh one one guy was in his 50s
and he says doctor recommended he got it
he's absolutely fine he feels great if
you choose to do it I don't care what
you choose to do I'm not gonna pretend
to be a doctor I'm not going to pretend
to know the secret to the universe but I
will stand up and say [ __ ] the
government if they're gonna tell you hey
you're obligated to get a permanent
medical procedure otherwise you can't
work you can't eat food you can't go to
the movies Jim let's fact check this
fauci engage came out last week in
videos I played like 50 times people
could pull this up and they both said oh
sorry it really doesn't work or do
anything we've got a new vaccine coming
out after six months there's no
basically no immunity from the shot
that's not a vaccine
come on come on come on the challenge
with this stuff is no no no but Joe tell
them I'm up here I mean I could yeah it
wanes it wanes after time well the real
problem is it's unscientific because
they don't recognize the natural
immunity from previous infection like if
you have a real infection with covid and
you recover you have a more robust
natural immunity it's been shown by that
Israeli study which is 2.5 million
people that are between 6 and 13 times
better immunity than you got from the
vaccine
so they negate this and they pretend
that it's difficult to to measure but
it's not difficult at all we do it in my
studio all the time you do a very simple
test for antibodies you can see it very
clearly if it's a you know it's you do
this this test you get a drop of blood
and you see your immunity you find out
that you have antibodies it's not hard
if that's the case that's just as good
not just as good let's be kind and say
it's as good but let me add this far
better it's far better than you get if
you got infected yeah hold on he got
coveted he recovered so he has six to 13
times better immunity than someone who
gets the vaccine has like two weeks
recovery from the vaccine and now can go
out into the world he's a better better
average I'll say two things the first is
that I think politically this uh
is a pitch rep because a pit trap a
trick you walk and then you stumble
through the leaves and you fall into the
spikes because right now they're saying
we are going to mandate three shots in
the UK Austria France and then what
happens is you end up with Rand Paul who
I like the guy but he says why aren't we
taking natural immunity into the into
the case and I said why are you in any
way excusing mandates for medical
procedures whether it be a test or a
shot if if we're talking about natural
immunity we're talking about you going
to a facility it's taking time out of
your day to get a medical test done if
you want to buy food no no no he's
taking one step he's taking one step in
this examination of this narrative in
their Direction once no no no he's
saying
one step in the navigation of this
narrative is to look at what you're
ignoring yeah so are you allowed to talk
about natural you're ignoring natural
immunity well I know your your whole
case is [ __ ] so everything you say
whether you're in for mandates whether
you're telling children they have to get
it whatever the [ __ ] you're saying as
soon as you say your natural immunity
from previous infection doesn't account
or you try to pretend that it's
impossible to check when you can check
in seconds if you vaccinate someone
they're not good for two weeks you can
check their immunity in seconds I have a
[ __ ] video of my phone of me doing it
let me just say this the FDA put a
letter out last week under a four-year
lawsuit and they said no one that we've
looked at over millions who had natural
immunity has ever transmitted the virus
but everyone that takes the vaccine can
at the same level I don't buy that I
think people just haven't reported
whether or not they transmitted the
virus and they're not as simple it's
like you have to like somehow or another
they have to like quantify that you had
the virus and then gave it to somebody
else
I know I know different things yeah
someone who gets uh this is this is
exactly what they say if you hit the
vaccine you're I think it's an order of
magnitude less likely to get sick and
it's less severe if you do get sick
you're equally likely to transfer the
virus someone else just came out and
said that's not true anymore I have the
freaking clip right right after a while
you're still going to get sick I've had
three friends now be hospitalized that
were vaccinated well so so we had
hospitalized with coven wait the
elephant in the room listen the elephant
in the room look at the border okay why
is it if the federal government is so
concerned with covet spreading in the
United States of America why is it that
Americans have to go on lockdown why is
it that Americans have to receive these
mandatory job mandates but there are
millions of people since Biden has taken
office that have flooded over the United
States Southern border not a single
vaccine mandate has been issued to these
people that are not even Americans you
want to know it's pissing Americans off
right now whether left or right is that
there are people that are coming from
different countries freely over the
southern border without any job mandates
but Americans are losing their lives
First Responders medical examiners
people that are professionals people
that have dedicated their lives that are
experts that are now being put out on
the streets they're Americans and that
is what's bothering the governor of the
document just came out we gotta say this
I don't wanna I the document just came
out the Minnesota Governor said he
inflate covet numbers okay the shutdown
this is what really really annoys me
about all this Drew just made a massive
political point and everybody keeps
going back into the argument about we
should we should all sit under the
mandates but discuss the science when no
one here knows what the [ __ ] they're
talking about what I do know is that a
million plus people did cross the border
with not a single mandate but they are
firing nurses and then people argue
natural immunity and they argue big and
I'm like I don't care about any of that
you are not going to mandate a public
policy on the people and then ban people
drew go ahead the government for sure
it's a power move yeah but but why is I
100 percent said I want to lock down for
power he admits the role of fraud this
is smoking yes no listen this is why I
am so hell-bent on talk to your doctor
we're not going to discuss yeah why is
the Minnesota governor no no stop doing
that dude you are driving us back into
an argument that takes a away from the
fact that they are mandating a medical
procedure I don't care if it's an x-ray
I don't care if it's a physical I don't
care if they want to feel my toes we
shouldn't be sitting here going like
well this scientist said this and they
were talking about numbers no a million
people cross the southern border with no
mandate firefighters police nurses fired
from their jobs and all anyone keeps
doing is keep saying let's have a
conversation about efficacy no I
agreement is irrelevant you talk to your
doctor you figure out what makes sense
for you and I'll tell you this your
mandates are meaningless yeah it's two
different arguments I agree with you
nobody disagree I'm saying the the
governor of them don't know most people
don't know most people don't know let's
talk more about that the Minnesota
Governor admits the lockdown was for
political control he got caught in
emails sorry yeah well how many people
know that people are literally not just
being allowed across the border but
actually like allowed to enter into the
country yeah we've got to do that to fly
on airplanes
if you're coming legally you have to
have the covid vaccine now and again we
don't understand this was never about
your health this was always about your
subjugation you look at what happened
where they mandate this medical
procedure where they have the most
strictest vaccine passports in England
in Israel in Singapore you see the
highest rises in cases Gibraltar one of
the most vaccinated places in the world
Singapore just canceled Christmas
because they had a surge in covet cases
Vermont has the highest cases in America
and it's the highest facts exactly
that's all Bernie Sanders fault that's
what I heard it is no you know they want
they want to control we've talked about
this Alex right they want a controllable
class they want a two-tier system they
want the Elites at the top and they want
the people at the bottom that they could
control that are not going to say
anything that are not going to protest
that are not going to fuss about it
because they want people come millions
of people they want people in this
country that are illiterate to the
United States Constitution so that they
don't protest or fuss about it it's not
left or right democrat or republican
they just want people that they could
control and what's happening at the
southern border is literally proving
that right now as I speak it's not
stopping it's not stopping is why I tell
people it doesn't matter it's not left
or right it's not Republican or
Democratic okay
ever starts yelling okay let me let me
correct this Sean Hannity just
everybody's saving lives the Americans
don't care about the Constitution this
is just Boomer bullcrap that people
spout on Fox News so you think the
United States Constitution is Boomer
bullcrap is that what you're saying
Russia is interesting 100 Russia if you
looked at what happened Russia if you
look at what happened with the lockdowns
they did not have to use a lot of force
the overwhelming majority of people were
more than happy to have their freedoms
taken away for the illusion of safety
the average man does not want to be free
he merely wants to be safe and the
Constitution
No One's Gonna know that reference and
the Constitution has been a dead letter
from the George Washington
administration they were locking people
up for criticizing the government in the
1790s it's a complete joke we said
wars.com
their Mine Fields before us where they
they they pull you in their direction
I've talked about how the conservatives
that there's no real opposition to the
left other than like the Democrats will
come out and say we want to ban assault
rifles and the Republicans will say no
but where is the Republican leadership
this is actually something you told me
where is the Republican leadership come
out and say we want to abolish gun laws
everything is always the establishment
left is pulling us in this direction and
the right is just saying slow down say
the quote conservatism is progressivism
driving the speed limit oh there you go
so this is why you know we had a
conversation a while ago about science
and Pfizer and all these pills and stuff
and I was like yo are we actually just
arguing the degree to which we are going
to live under the mandates I agree but
what about the Exodus of the people from
Main Street Media Joe everything's
collapsing your show is the epicenter of
everybody leaving the establishment and
going to Independent how does how does
dinosaur media finally die because if
Joe Rogan's the meteorite to hit the
planet kill dinosaurs it doesn't have to
die am radio's still around too
well let's just say let it just like let
let's keep it alive
let's keep it alive barely Alex do you
know who you want you don't want your
enemy to die you want you to keep your
foot on its chest looks like a little
zombie you know how it's gonna you know
how it's gonna you know it's how it's
gonna lose it it's gonna lose its
efficacy when CNN and fox and MSNBC are
looked at exactly like a look at
Marlboro or Lucky Strikes when the
average American regards a corporate
journalist exactly as they regard
tobacco executive you know they're
selling your product you know that
product's deadly let them sell it yeah
but people want to buy it but that's all
it is Lucky Strikes gives you a nice
Head Rush well so does watching these
shows because you hate the Liberals you
hate the conservatives Lucky Strikes you
get to go to flavor country for a little
bit now how much are filterables we
should ask ourselves how much support
does the corporate media have and how
much of it is an illusion they don't
anymore yes
the average CNN show has a hundred
thousand viewers if they're lucky right
yeah but we know that of them are
actually like into it right how many of
us just flip into the channels Joe Rogan
farts he gets five million views but if
you if you like if you're flipping
through the channels are you really into
it is it something you're looking
forward to I mean how many people are
actually looking forward to well you're
like look at Brian stelter he's a sack
of Filth he's a fake fraud the [ __ ] are
you saying like they seek the
personalities all right I love him I
actually have a sexual desire I'm still
on this I think the corporate media is
now alphabet Google Facebook will meta
uh right and how do we face this in the
next 20 years if they're smart what they
would do is go back to straight news
straight objective just have all the
apps a plane crash have all the ads you
want but have objective
completely unbiased news if they did
that I think it would turn it around if
we knew that everyone that was reading
all the news if we get to a point
through all these independent social
media applications and the distribution
of information when we know what they're
saying is verified we know it's true so
they have to tell the truth if they just
told the truth and give you a synopsis
of what's happening in the world they
would actually make more money
it's not possible because at the very
least they're gonna have a bias in terms
of what they cover what they don't maybe
or maybe they just get together with a
panel that decides like what is the most
important in terms of National Security
the economy well all the different
things about climate what what are the
issues that are really that we know are
real that we can cover in an unbiased
way if someone came along and did that I
guarantee you you would get enough of
people from both sides once it's been
clearly established that it's actually
unbiased news I think they would be
massively commercially successful but
look at look at the irony and they do it
by showing them all times let's take a
look at breaking points with Crystal and
cigar soccer perfect example but no
they're getting smeared as alt right and
far right now bunch of [ __ ]
but Their audience that's that's true
there's a there's an issue with this
this idea of the left populists and the
right popular less can come challenge
the elites Crystal and cigar were
saggers
[ __ ] say his name more time soccer
soccer
Braveheart so uh we did a segment on the
show uh Young Turks said that you know
Joe Rogan's basically Alex Jones or took
a crossing at this point and people
responded saying so is Crystal and Sagar
and and I when they why are we listening
to sink turd it's not it's not about why
are we it's about why does he have
millions of subscribers and get 30
million
why are you distracting me when I have
to leave you keep going down these dark
alleys oh dude
I love the idea that we can bring
everyone together but some people are
just diametrically opposed to what we
believe yes after a while you watch that
guy talk and you're like all right let
me get a question
silly people let me get a question hold
on there's so many [ __ ] silly people
people you know like you don't have to
take into consideration their statements
about every [ __ ] thing that happens
with every person you realize they're
silly you know they're silly that's why
you brought them up ignore no no I
didn't bring him because he's silly I
brought him up because he gets tens of
millions of views yes he he does he does
he's not if you look at all the views
but how many of how many individual
unique people are there it's not tens of
millions no no I'm saying I'm not
talking about unique I'm just saying but
it's the same [ __ ] people it's like
tens of millions of people they put out
a lot of content they have a hundred
thousand okay that's one question should
I ask one question but it doesn't matter
do you agree with them or disagree with
them you don't if you don't agree with
them you don't have to keep bringing
them up over and over and over again
just [ __ ] ignore them they're always
irrelevant as you as we make them yeah
that's just one question disagree
because I've been bigger the media for
20 something years you've been huge
forever that's why they cut your nose
this is a real question no you don't
want to sound rock star or arrogate yeah
it's a horrible person yeah [ __ ] you
it's fast Nicholson
answer the question what is it like to
not just be probably the most famous
person like a president right now in the
world but to have done it independently
on your own that's a major sea change I
celebrate that I'm blessed to know you
you're a great guy what is it like to be
at the epicenter that if I thought about
that I'd be [ __ ] well it's a real
question tell me I don't know
black helicopters okay but you have but
that sounds like as you've gotten it
seems like as you've gotten right in the
middle of the site guys you've gotten
more politically involved not because
you wanted to but you felt like you
needed to because now this it's not that
I got in the middle of the Zeitgeist
this pandemic yeah exposed the fragility
of our society that so many people are
willing to give up their freedom for
this like bizarre fake security that
doesn't exist like you're talking about
the most the most unsecure thing ever a
pandemic virus that's going through
people and then a solution a medical
solution that doesn't entirely work and
everybody's like forcing you to get
involved and take this and ignore all
risks because they did and they want you
to be on their side it's Madness and as
soon as you see that kind of Madness if
you don't say something then you fall
into tyranny and that's what the [ __ ] is
happening and whether or not people
realize what they're doing these most of
the people that are doing that are
cowards because if you stand up and you
say hey I don't think you should
vaccinate children
thank you
they're scared like you can't even have
to I can't pull in your cars but here's
the thing about it here's the thing
about you and here's the thing about me
when someone is unvaccinated and they
survives Kobe pretty [ __ ] quick they
go wait a minute I know that was
available right and you go well how you
know when I made a video like three days
after I had covered I'm like I feel
pretty good like lies and then two days
later I put up this [ __ ] this test
it's like Tim said they were Maddie
survived yeah man I survived too but you
know it's because they took the chance
and they got vaccinated and they feel
like you should have done that too
because they realize there's a certain
amount of risk involved and they got
through it they're like you [ __ ] do
it it's like I jumped into the water
from the cliff you jump jump pitch I
jumped what about Aaron Rodgers who I
know you've helped out as well I mean
they're demonizing him calling him a
white supremacist on ESPN I'm I'm
flipping
I swear to God I'm flipping through
it was a sports show and I'm flipping
through cable what's his name they call
them right wing where's Skip Bayless
where's Skip Bayless the other football
guy Skip Bayless the big black guy and
all I know is they go he's a white
nationalist oh that guy's not a white
nationalist that's but this is like
people say things to get a lot of
attention and they say things as maybe
they even mean it with that here's the
thing with Aaron Rodgers that guy in any
other time in history if a friend calls
you up and goes hey man you add the flu
what did you do I say oh I took a z-pack
I took a this I took of that that was
better in a couple I got a vitamin
infusion that's really big that helped
me a lot and they go okay I'm gonna try
that and they do it they get better and
they go thanks everybody's happy oh I
would like to do what Aaron Rodgers did
if I get sick because he was he was
better pretty quick oh Joe Rogan did
that oh I should do what they did
because I'll get better pretty quick I'm
not saying don't get vaccinated I'm
saying if you do get sick this is what I
did and this is how I got better all the
decisions you make outside of that are
on your own I'm just telling you what I
did you mean you mean Pfizer lets us
hear from you
beings decide the influence that Pfizer
has is minimal in comparison the
influence we have I agree I agree that's
what the real problem is is when people
do things they make a choice they want
everybody else but you got better in two
days Tim got better in a couple days it
worked right I took yo yo joe joe I was
taking Ivermectin then I know you I was
right I know you really I think I was
but like Ian was also really bad but the
reason the reason the reason I called is
because I was like I talked to a doctor
they said look it's a virus sleep at all
but here's the thing it's monoclonal
antibodies or the big thing I took when
I said that I took Ivermectin I said I
took it in a laundry list of other
things that I took and I didn't say that
first I said monocle to antibodies I
said z-pack I said Ivermectin I said all
these things but all they focused on was
Ivermectin but Joe the thing monoclonal
antibodies are super effective it's been
proven and they're authorized for
emergencies yes it is a it's a totally
authorized and the company's been around
since 1988. they're not like giving
liability protection that's why I trust
them oh look but Alex I also
no one knows you got better in two days
you got better than three I got better
like a day with this stuff Aaron Rodgers
how fast he get better somebody's never
even sick he's playing soon he played he
just won on Sunday so he never even got
sick with the pro no he was sick before
that he wasn't feeling good he asked me
what I did I told him I connected him
with some people and he at his doctor
got him all the proper medications that
he needed and monoclonal antibodies and
all the other stuff and he got better
fairly quickly after us but also he's a
[ __ ] super athlete all right we're
not talking about like your 85 year old
grandmother yeah we're talking about a
legit NFL quarterback [ __ ] super
athlete so to comparing him to the
average normal Joe walking on the street
is crazy he's literally the elite of the
elite in terms of professional analog
and I love you I love you too [ __ ]
so he's bouncing out everybody
and Joe keep in mind
got a big guest tomorrow Joe tomorrow
the verdict might come in oh
it's going to be chaos
yeah yeah yeah I know he's gonna be
crazy that's why we told Drew to stick
around we were like Drew we got you got
to stick around now everyone's talking
who's taking selfies while joking you're
supposed to be switching you're supposed
to be switching
switching do your job
a chance talk yeah
I just went into a legit Vortex that was
crazy oh man so right now for those that
are watching uh a good portion of the
crew everyone's saying goodbye they're
peace out uh Joe actually has a show
he's playing it and that's why you know
when everyone was like Hey if we're
gonna have all these people get Joe and
I think he's got a show he's not gonna
be but Joe was like dude I'm gonna do it
you was here I was like he's he's not
taking it from anybody he's telling
everybody to shut up he's a team player
he let everyone know what they needed to
know and the show's not over guys Alex
is coming back
um
I'm sorry Blair I'm sorry you have to
hey you're you're good again Ian's gonna
come on in so the show again this is the
part two of the show and I think we're
gonna go for another hour
I want to see if I'm still bleeding yeah
I'll grab you something yeah can someone
grab you I need a water as Alex yeah
Alex is coming back and basically only
Joe has to peace out because he's got
his show to do and uh this is when we
start talking about psilocybin
who likes psilocybin raise your hand I'm
I'm like I said suicide no no no I I
like thank you sir I like talking about
the things that Michael talks about you
know like uh uh police Constitution
Freedom Liberty that's my that's my jam
and um I don't know if you saw that rant
I did where they got really mad at me
and of course I saw it I was my porn my
sheets are ruined it was because you
were dewormed that it changed you I know
it's funny but like that's not the first
rant I've ever had there's a video from
our old Studio where I'm like they went
to this dude's house in Wisconsin and
were protesting in front of his house
they had set the same protesters set
fire to a house before and when the guy
brandished a shotgun the police came and
arrested him from his own house and I
was like these people will come to your
home they will protest you these these
activists obviously and the police will
kick in your door and they will bash
your teeth in and then they're like dude
but the reason the left got mad was a
reaction to the right the right was like
look at this epic rant from is like
saying that the federal law enforcement
went for James O'Keefe I would I was
surprised you know what's really funny
about this is when when that with that
rant the left came out angry at me and
I'm like I was literally saying I
literally abolished the police I was
like abolish the police like the feds
kicked in James O'Keefe stores his
federal law enforcement they leaked his
privileged legal Communications this is
a violation of every core tenant this
country is supposed to believe in you're
privileged access to legal assistance
and then the left was like haha he's bad
that's Fascism and I'm like I thought I
was agreeing with you I want to ask a
drew a question Mr Constitution uh given
what you saw in Kenosha what is your
perspective on the police uh my
perspective is that the police are going
to have to start making some serious
decisions soon because if they're not
going to sign aside with their
constitutional Oaths
um they are literally betraying the
American people so I think when police
are getting into that type of territory
they're going to start enforcing a
police state so I think right now where
we are with the Advent of uh Marxism
cultural Marxism becoming mainstream I
think the excuse when police come out
and say I'm just doing my job is what
the Nazi says so I think right now uh
that is a crime against humanity and I
think when police aren't uh having the
will to say you know what I'm not going
to enforce this I'm going to continue to
do my job I think uh they're gonna have
to make that decision but if they do do
that if they decide not to and pull out
of it I think that uh that's something
they need to consider before they become
police officers because if you're going
to take a job like that you're going to
have to be prepared to make a decision
whether I'm going to obey
unconstitutional or illegal edicts or
mandates or I am going to uh resign
another way I just got one quick
question given that all gun laws are
unconstitutional violate the Second
Amendment uh what do you think of police
officers that arrest people who have
guns uh that might be in violation
second men who are otherwise peaceful
people repeat it one more time police
who enforce gun laws which are all
unconstitutional against peaceful
citizens what do you think of those
police and speak more into the mic your
audio is low low is my audio low yeah
yeah
I just think that police I think the
biggest issue right now with police
officers and I've talked to many of them
I've had conversations with them I think
a lot of them are really like illiterate
to the law itself not all of them but
every time you talk to one of them like
they're really not sure how they're
enforcing the law correctly like they're
not even aware of some of the laws
themselves they're just completely
ignoring my question yeah uh gun laws
are all unconstitutional what do you
think of police officers who enforce gun
laws against peaceful citizens
I think the Second Amendment is for all
Americans right so what do you think
again for the third time what do you
think of police officers who enforce gun
laws against peaceful citizens I think
that's just something they're gonna have
to decide to do whether they're going to
do it or not well what do you think of
them that's what I think that they're
just gonna have to just gonna shrug your
shoulders decision so if a cop arrests
someone who has a handgun illegally
who's not hurting anybody or has some
kind of red flag thing what do you think
of that police officer who puts that
person in jail yeah I don't think that's
a good thing but what do you think about
individual the individual the individual
police officer yeah that's what I just
said yeah they're evil are they yeah but
you said that's not a good thing you
know me burning a cake is not a good
thing as well yeah the human being the
same is his name is the same question
over and over officer Johnson you're not
answering it let me also not all right
hold on let me let me phrase let me
phrase the question there was a woman I
tell the story all the time who was from
Pennsylvania with a legal gun and drove
into New Jersey and will give the cop a
name officer John Smith pulled her over
and he said you know your tail lights
out or whatever and she he said you have
a weapon on you said yes I do and he
says oh okay she politely informed him
but in New Jersey you can't have it so
he took her out he coughed her and they
tried putting her in prison for four
years how do you feel about John Smith
I mean I I would have to really take a
look at the entire situation okay I'm
not trying to avoid anything I just
don't want to say
cops are leaving because of the backs
there's no decent box well I was just
gonna make a correction and say no I
probably thinks there are none but good
meaning cops a lot of them are leaving
right you're right that's true and I
disagree with Michael on that I think
there are decent cops but I understand
your point about the institution as a
whole but I I think there are I've I've
met cops who have been
that they've actually sought to like
stop violent criminals and rapists and
murderers no question and I've seen
these cops be like I'm not going to stop
some kid for you know this that or
otherwise I will also correct you you
said all gun laws are unconstitutional
yes what if the gun law was that you had
to have a gun uh that actually was the
case in America the colonial period And
I if you look it up I have an article in
The Observer that says must pack heat
arguing for using Obamacare as a
mechanism to mandate gun ownership
criminals aren't going to follow laws
anyways
well no so we're talking about what uh
Michael had said all gun laws are
unconstitutional my question is what if
a gun law mandated you do own a gun like
that's unconstitutional it is
unconstitutional it's not unconstitution
Switzerland makes you do it that's a
form of indigenous servitude owning a
gun is of indentured Services no if you
make somebody own a gun that's a
disreservator who are you a servant who
are you in servitude to who who's making
me own a gun I thought you're Anarchist
I am an anarchist the point being it's
either if I disagree with you about
classifying something if it made you
join an anarchist Collective to have a
gun and you willfully joined it as part
of a member this isn't that new the
anarchism I don't explain to me how
mandating gun ownership or mandating
health insurance is indenture servitude
I mean now you're forced inoculations
you didn't answer my question
insurance and an offer forced gun
ownership I'm I'm mad at you Michael I'm
just telling you I just don't understand
ex can you maybe this is my autism
speaking can you explain to me how
mandating someone owning a product is
indentured servitude as opposed to
unlawful uh
um all I know is under my Common Sense
freedom and under what I want I don't
have to own a gun
circles let's not go in circles I think
he was just using the phrase incorrectly
oh okay yeah okay I think I think the
point is like I I remember uh when when
I think it was Illinois mandated seat
belts I don't know when they exactly
mended seat belts but I remember having
a conversation about do you have the
right to not wear a seat belt well not
anymore you don't and then I had a
conversation from there about how you're
forced I remember when ObamaCare was
coming through and people were like what
about auto insurance the law the
government makes you buy auto insurance
no one cares about that and I was like
actually I I kind of do I you know I I
like I I of course would always want to
carry insurance but that's on a state
level as well the idea the government
would mandate you buy a private product
and then regulate that product to like
guarantee now they use it as an example
oh you got to buy insurance you got to
wear seatbelts you got to take a shot I
say I'm more of an anarchist than malice
I guess oh
listen you're no Santa Claus I'm not
sitting on that lap
so so we're playing who could Anarchist
out the anarchists by books right behind
you yeah
I watch your show I watched him I know
you're an electron they're actually
genuinely smart respect you I'm just
saying I agree with Anarchist precepts
but informing that and injecting that
into the real world does not work I
disagree until it's scalability it's
complete anarchism is in a location it's
a relationship so this show right now is
an example anarchism there's a lot more
anarchism than we know centralization is
when we have government when we have fat
cat bureaucrat mafioso's coming in and
saying I want to cut to that it's
centralization decentralization is
anarchy decentralization exactly so I'm
so you're for your Anarchy and I'm
foreign because that's the true
definition of it with no one intervening
no one forcing you to do something
that's the basic core concept
philosophies of Anarchy which should be
respected and talked about properly
that's why I had to correct Joe Rogan
when he said this was Anarchy no it
wasn't as a state-sponsored terrorism
Alex knows about that give me 30 seconds
I'll shut up for 10 minutes I promise I
don't believe that that is a lie that is
not true
I would like to give everybody
just exploded get a timer right now
for 10 minutes
no no no no timer ready yeah I want you
to hear this ready shut up
I actually
actually I know you all and I really
appreciate with the producer to
everybody and I this has just been
historic and Joe is so amazing and all
you guys and Tim thank you for having me
here you're right it Israel Anarchy and
it's beautiful and I love you all and I
appreciate being here my my favorite
thing I think all of this was I was like
we we end up we the show started with us
having Blair to come on and then you
know Alex was like I was like maybe then
you all hijacked me we hijacked it but
the best part was the very end when
everyone's like have you asked Joe and
I'm like he's busy and then Joe's like
yeah yeah I could probably come in where
are y'all at and I'm like we're in a
trailer on the side of the road and so
he's like it's a very nice it's like it
is really really great and I just think
it's hilarious that you know was it you
said it like a step down or something
like the mighty have fallen oh yeah yeah
Joe Rogan coming from his massive
amazing new awesome Studio to my trailer
on the side of the world he loves you
too no I know obviously you know he
always loved you but after you destroyed
Twitter with him he like puts you at the
top tier you know what's funny though
that we had beef
I didn't know that tell the story for
dinner
so so
um it's not too complicated Joe uh
someone back in like during occupy era
somebody tweeted at Joe when his podcast
wasn't as big they were like you gotta
have Tim pool in the show and then he
tweeted me like yeah for sure man why
don't you come and hang out and I said
cool so you know I was young and
bright-eyed and naive and I was kind of
like this is Joe Rogan this is right
back in 2011 money so not the biggest
show in the world but it's come on my
show but but well I didn't know who you
were evaluated I'm Alex I remember
telling Luke hey get me get me get me
Temple well so check it out check it out
so I flew to LA and once I landed he
messaged me like bro I'm really sorry to
do this to you I can't have you on the
show something came up and I went
I just flew out to California and so I
made the best of it there's some
protests I covered a year later same
thing happened somebody tweeted Joe like
how come you never had Tim pool on your
show now 2012 and he was like yo we
tried to make it happen it didn't happen
Tim what do you say come on the show and
I was like let's do it this time I was
like I wanna I wanna make sure we we
confirm this like because he gave me the
details before I'm like give me the
details give me the time give me
everything and he does and that's why I
get on the plane I paid for it myself
because I'm young and naive and I fly to
California and then he says bro I'm so
sorry I'm doing this to you I can't have
you on oh my God some things come up and
I was just like all right now I'm really
mad and I was like dude are you kidding
me it's like a year later you did the
same thing and I thought to myself I was
like look I'm obviously mad about it but
Joe doesn't owe me any favors me going
on this show would be really great for
me so I was just like that's the story
and then what ended up happening I was
like I'm just not gonna I'm not gonna be
mad about it because he doesn't owe me
anything and I'm just gonna I'm gonna
focus on my thing I'm not gonna beg him
I'm not gonna ask him and I just want
about my business and then a couple
years later Joseph messaged me and he
was like bro I just want to let you know
like I am really sorry about you know
having canceled on you like that now
it's beautiful I don't want there to be
any beef or anything and I was like nah
dude there's no there's no salt there's
no beef like it was just like it
happened twice in in in Spanish but let
me tell you about Joe in the old days he
was doing so much comedy almost every
day and his other jobs he
we were gonna do his podcast forever and
he would cancel it too he just used to
like the podcast was a side thing and
then starting about six years ago he
made it to main tank and that's what
happened I don't feel as bad now because
there was two times where Joe invited me
on and it didn't happen I didn't fly out
but um and then I just checked my phone
before I went on I have a mess DM from
him from two weeks ago asking me to come
on I'm like why am I now it's my fault
yeah he knew who you were like oh hi
Blair and I was like well why aren't you
on the show now here's look here's the
craziest thing here's the crazy story
you haven't seen us taking acid in Vegas
can we hear about that story I would
love that you guys want to hear the
Twitter story because I don't gotta I I
want to hear the acid story or the Toy
Story is more more than the Twitter
story I'll tell you a Joe Rogan story
well
can we is it is it is it is it something
where you're like maybe I should have
brought that up because it's a story I
probably shouldn't tell or are you going
to now the big question is which story
should it be yeah the wild one the crazy
one so when you're right you've seen the
movie like The Hangover yes this
happened before a few
member like
actually you get Joe on next time he'll
tell you but I mean I remember like two
days later because I was not a big you
know two days later like not knowing
where we've been in like in Vegas with
him because he's like if you I went up
and saw some of the fights in Vegas
other places where Joey might get me
tickets he was a great guy and so I
remember like
okay we're at ESPN and we're on air and
this is going on I'm in a control room
and Joe is whatever and like two days
later I'm like what what happened she
was like I'll see you later I've been on
a plane so it's pretty wild man pretty
well but Joe's not like that now he but
he's definitely done some partying yeah
I mean let me tell you I've sat there
with Joe
because now we go out he might drink
like two beers
and you guys in great shape everything
but I remember like I mean like like two
days up with him and he wasn't on any
trap of amphetamines it was all just
Joe's energy and we're like drinking
like 20 shots at like 4 a.m up for two
days and like taking Edibles and all
those friends I mean this dude's like a
thoroughbred I mean a thoroughbred man
that's why he takes the horse paste yeah
so no but Joey Diaz wants like we're
sitting there goes like icky's eat these
Edibles and she was like haha we just
took acid and I don't remember two days
yeah
any Revelations any reality shattering
moments any kind of like Clarity in your
life it was fun except I remember and
this is to Joe's Credit this is like 15
years ago 60 17 years ago this big we're
in Vegas we're there two days before the
fight like a day after the fights were
there like four days
so two days before one day the five day
after and I just remember I'm like why
don't you take the the elevator to your
limo he loved his fan so much that I
remember like hallucinating on acid
while Joe signed thousands of autographs
because he's trying to go through the
casino once they start piling up and I
remember just like Dave like like
hallucinating for like a day of him
signing off like like like it's like
it's crazy you know well there's like
some cool story like naked chicks and
that's not it's Joe yeah but that's not
cool that's not the cool stuff the cool
stuff is the depot taking photos yeah
selfies with people yeah and signing
autographs yeah so I asked I asked Joe
and I don't I don't know if like I don't
know if he gave us like a robust answer
he gave a little bit you know from the
from the time I went on and we talked
with Twitter but even before that to
where he is now how his view has changed
I think it's fair to say you can see in
Joe a big change
so that that first interview he did with
Jack Dorsey was back in 2018 I guess he
was just like let Jack say yes and say
whatever he wanted and then he got
heavily thumbs down for it we do our
show here we are today and he's saying
they're censoring it's coming from the
left and that's definitive he's seen it
I think there's two Factor there's two
things here for one like Joe really
started to understand and see what was
going on as things got worse but it's
also that things are getting worse
I want to make sure I preface that by
saying Freedom loving individuals
liberty-minded individuals are winning
many battles across the board but in the
censorship stuff as this becomes the new
corporate press it is getting worse and
I mean I think the reality is we're not
long for this world you know everyone's
like you know I see the comments like
wow Tim you really pulled this thing
together and I'm like yeah but there
will come a time the cliffs are eroding
and over time they are homogenizing what
YouTube is and they want it to be that
mainstream narrative Jimi Hendrix yeah
but but they know
the sand dumps in the semen but let me
just say this one thing because I don't
[ __ ] when it comes to things like
this
Tim was a turning point for Joe and I'm
not going to get our private phone calls
and things because Joe wanted to believe
in the system and wanted to believe
there were good guys bad guys and when
he he remember him I'm not gonna tell a
little story every caller he goes you
see whatever Temple and I said yeah I
heard about thank you I'm under attack
he goes well it's true Joe already had
all that understanding but as soon as so
it's true Tim that like you're like the
vampire that bit Joe Rogan
no no no no no no no I'm not just
kissing your ass that was the point I
told you that privately that was the
point but Tim that Jack Dorsey moment
was a corner shed moment that shattered
the reality of a lot of people's
understanding of how things work online
and you were there you didn't fall for
their traps you went around their traps
I was like slapped up slapped them
upside their head and and then they're
like they didn't know what they were
doing so again another thing
yeah and something else to add here
you're saying we're not long for this
world we're long for a very long time
they can't pull the rug because if they
do they lose everything they're slowly
pulling the rug they hit Alex but Alex
is still here Alex is still producing
his videos Alex is getting a crap tone
of viewership
and we all survive no matter what and
and we've got timcast.com yeah that's
right where you should sign up become a
member for our special members only
segments because I I realized this a
long time ago but didn't really have the
skill the experience but the beginning
of this year I was like if we don't have
our own website yeah we could get
plucked right out and thrown in the
trash exactly but not anymore yep but
there's also one factor one thing
there's one factor you guys both missed
which is there's a big difference when
you watch the news and you see that
they're lying about you personally yeah
if Joe's Joe had his podcast him growing
out talking to fighter stock comedians
just hanging out you trying to hold on
Al and you've experienced for a long
time you turn the news and it's
something that you have personal
knowledge about and you see people
you've never met explicitly lying about
you and lies that are easily verified to
be lies that's when you realize wait a
minute something is up and it's happened
to you as well obviously you know Tim I
re-watch I rewatched that the other day
YouTube recently you know and what I
found interesting was how the point you
made how they kept saying we do this to
protect people because if there's a
threat to somebody's life through social
media we take action on it right and the
reason why I thought that was
interesting is because like even as of
recently after I testified in the trial
I started getting death threats on
Instagram am on Twitter all this stuff
and what was crazy on Instagram was I
actually took a screenshot they don't
care of someone yeah of someone issuing
me a death threat I posted it and my
account
if it was if it was me what about Kelly
Paul Van Paul's wife always complains to
Twitter because he gets like I'm glad
the neighbor did this this happened
again she's like Jack do something and
he's like I don't care they're on
Twitter
I'm Rand Paul's neighbor wow so so uh
one of the points that I brought up to
uh Jack and Vijaya on that show was they
said
you know we're trying to protect people
there's High suicide rates and I said
what about people with like body
dysmorphia where uh they cut their hands
off you know that these people exist are
you going to create special rules for
for these groups I think the the
fascinating thing about that moment and
it comes up a lot I guess because for me
it was just a moment I was there and I
was having a typical argument I would
normally have with anybody but I guess a
lot of people didn't realize this stuff
they didn't realize
um vagina and Jack didn't realize when
they were entering this they thought
they were going to be getting your
run-of-the-mill conservatives was going
to be like why'd you ban Milo why'd you
ban Alex instead of more like
philosophical and like liberty-minded
questions and like fairness and and yeah
they ran out they bled out on on to 10
million viewers they bled out it was
that and then the Sanjay Gupta thing I
think woke a lot of people that was the
thing with Joe because it was one of the
very few maybe even the only instance
where you have someone who's on CNN
every day lying and you have someone
actually confronting them to their face
and then you go back to watch CNN
afterwards and they completely edit out
that interaction they completely frame
it as him somehow convincing Joe Rogan
to be pro-boxing but the crazy thing
about the CNN thing was that Sanjay
Sanjay Gupta goes on Joe's show and Joe
is like why would they lie and Sanjay
said they shouldn't have done that and
then Sanjay goes on Don Lemon and Don
Lemon says we didn't it was the truth
and Sanjay goes you're right that's all
true right that is a duplicitous
deceitful is a joke he's not a joke
that's the thing he's interviewing
Sesame Street characters he's definitely
a professional yeah on average has 80
000. to be fair we did like that
no no yeah we talked about it but he
interviewed Sesame Street characters on
his show promoting children to get the
vaccine that's literally what CNN's
doing when they're not eating human
beings
our children our children watching CNN
no but no no Sanjay Gupta is doing
Sesame Street
on their show
Sesame Street is on HBO our children
subscribe to HBO If the parents are
watching HBO on the apps are the
children being headed the HBO Max wait
you think you think non-children are
watching Sesame Street non-children of
course it's only children
if they're getting more than 10 children
when Sesame Street leaves PBS and goes
on HBO our parents putting it on ahead
no no it's on it's on it's on the
internet targeting children on YouTube
Tim I promise you that Sesame Street's
still very popular with the kids come
here yeah vibrant yeah I have a
four-year-old I think I think it's fair
to say that it's probably it's just let
me tell a real story that's fair I saw
this two weeks ago I got mad about it am
I I don't let my kids watch you got mad
about something I don't know I don't
want to watch a lot of TV but Alex
doesn't get my four-year-old daughter
like Saturday's like let me watch TV so
I give her the controller she knows how
to run it she somehow goes to Sesame
Street I'm watching Sanjay Gupta and
I've got my phone I go God I gotta shoot
video of my daughter standing in front
of the TV oh no don't do it my wife will
kill me but this happened yeah so I mean
literally my daughter Saturday was
watching it and that made me physically
ill I got the videos pulled up here CNN
Big Bird talks to Dr Gupta about
covid-19 vaccine fear second video
Sesame Streets Rosita gets her first
covid-19 vaccine dose CNN YouTube
channel again and the list goes on and
on and on I'll tell you what the problem
with this is you know my problem with
this is you ever see those commercials
where it's like ask your doctor if Paul
bestro is right for you and it's like
even those commercials wouldn't tell you
what the drug was but they would always
tell you to like just take it amongst
yourself for private consultation now
they're outright like children here's a
medication made just for you get it
going to the parking lot they did an
entire Sesame Street coronavirus town
hall for over an hour there is
apparently a precedent they have done
vaccine episodes in the past but I don't
think that accounts with the fact that
this vaccine is is different than past
vaccines
do all this and literally Saturday my
four-year-old goes give me the
controller and I'm sitting here on the
phone doing stuff literally like cooking
a steak on the grill in my living room
and you know in the living room
okay and like my daughter is watching
Sanjay gupt and I was like okay I turn
it off she throws a fit but I'm
literally it's literally everywhere man
you have actually watched it are they
actually like jabbing kids in the in the
they're dabbing yeah it's an elbow so
what do you think do you think this is
more about like visuals
what do you mean like do you think this
is more about like visuals for kids just
to see it so they grow up thinking it's
normal or do you think they're actually
trying to like educate little kids
they're not trying to educate anyone
they're trying to get the so basically
what happens is you go to school and the
teachers teach you to be docile and
submissive and then this is basically
the homework in a sense that this
carries on the lessons you're being
taught in the school by the entire
Cathedral why did the dog bite you
because it because I misgendered it
that's true why did the chicken cross
the street
to get to the other side probably
because well so I have chickens and
actually I would tell you there was a
black helicopter chasing it down the
street oh man well we had a hawk attack
on our chickens a Black Hawk it was you
know well I mean it was the hawk was
black I don't know
flew over and the chickens all right
why did the chicken cross the road oh
probably because they weren't looking to
scratch some dirt and get some Alex at
what point would you start red pilling
your kids or do you well that's the
problem I'm I'm letting my children
alone and I've got four children so
one's like 19 117 one's 13 ones four but
I always think of my child as the
youngest one and I'm like that's why I
feel guilty so like she knows how to run
like I don't know how to turn the TV on
so I don't watch a lot of it it's like
all these shows I'm gonna put music on I
want my brother she's like and all of a
sudden Sanjay Gupta and I'm like
grilling a steak I'm like and I'm like
greatly eating it I'm like huh and then
like goop just do it so I go turn it off
I'm telling you my daughter is is like
like a demon Conjuring Sanjay Gupta so
this happened like five days ago so I
don't know what to do
I don't got kids don't look at me are
you just like you just like talk to her
like an adult like this is what the
world is doing you know I don't I want
to say I respect my children I do but
it's weird it's like I can't like tell a
four-year-old how things were they see
it so I'm just like we're turning Sanjay
off now and then she's throwing a fit
and she doesn't know why you know what
but like why is a dude telling my
daughter Alex do you know you do next
time I gotta turn this off this is this
is scary
that's what you tell her yeah it's very
scary well children are a lot more
conscious a lot more aware they actually
have a lot more DMT going through their
brain up until a certain age so they're
in touch in their Physical Realm and the
spiritual World a lot more than even the
human beings that's why they have such
vivid imagination because of the extra
DMT that they have that's right
Michael's shaking his head I just don't
know anything about dealing that's why
the pedophiles want to rape them okay uh
well anyway moving on Thomas Jefferson
was in the Illuminati he was the head of
the Illuminati what Alex talked about
which again we're trying to be a
family-friendly show but I think that's
out the window somehow has happened
throughout recorded human history oh
dude we are not going down that rabbit
hole that is this look yeah I you know
I'll tell you what frustrates me is um
racism uh I mean well yeah to be honest
but uh we we have people uh talking
about your kids and the things that that
you know the atrocities committed
against children but the manipulation we
have people who keep saying that they
won't don't stand up they won't defend
themselves because they have kids to
feed and I think it's just a remarkable
precedent to see that a whole year of
complying has resulted in food shortages
and inflation labor shortages Port Port
closures
and all of the all of these people who
are like I will not stand up for freedom
in my rights because I want to make sure
there's food on the table this is food
security for my children and now their
children are more at risk for it that's
a great point this is the most important
thing you've ever said or yes we
complied not us with the general public
and we dated we all did it and it made
it worse so submitting the Tyranny being
a cook made it worse so what do we do
I think there I think when you look at
how many states are controlled by
um I don't want to say Republicans but
it is it is people who are in the
Republican party I will point out to be
fair in New Hampshire the free Staters
are all running as Republicans and
they're and they're doing amazing work
and restoring Liberties and rights and
freedoms so here's what I think I think
we we're actually on a great path and if
you look at how many uh you look at the
recent elections with Pennsylvania and
and New Jersey and and Virginia
man the the the cathedral seems to be
losing a lot of power they seem to be in
a full-on panic mode you look at what
happened at the FBI and James O'Keefe
and that was the act of pure desperation
yes it was such an egregious violation
that even the ACLU and you know the Free
Press or whatever comes out and they're
like we have to defend James O'Keefe
because that went overboard but the FBI
was so panicked so scared so desperate
they made this pathetic move you kissed
so I was gonna say one thing you can't
look at Joe Biden as a symbol of an
Empire at the height of its strength
it's true right so here's what here's
what I see it looks like a tombstone
here's what I see I see I see good news
I see see all this stuff all this bad
stuff we talk about all the stuff that
scares us and all the concerns we have
about you know mandates and all that
stuff and then I see people talking
about a red tsunami I see people talk
and that's that's only going to be good
if people primary The Establishment good
I agree oh God that's so true but but
we're in trouble if we let establish
what Blue Blood Republicans get in if
it's a I don't care if it's a liberal or
conservative but a real populist consent
you're absolutely but I'm talking about
the house the Senate and more
importantly the state representatives
and the state senates that trucker who
won in New Jersey has got to be in my
opinion the greatest poster child a
victory a victory you know why because
he didn't do anything people
ocasio-cortez when she beats Crowley it
was because people were like anything
but these people again now she's playing
ball establishment but let's look at New
Jersey what's this what's a guy's name
Edder
he spends 153 bucks to file to run and
then just shrugs and then people are
like I'll take the ham sandwich over the
demo I agree that guy is the blue
first of all Alex you and I are old
enough to remember in 1994 the first
time Republicans to Congress in 40 years
everything's going to be different very
little was different from America
otherwise except for a balanced budget
very few things were different so I
disagree a little bit if there's going
to be a red wave in 2022 that that's
going to save America that's sad I agree
with you malice of course thank you but
can I helped our Red Wave for us Alex
one second Michael my point is the
victory is not going to come as a
consequence of government and elections
Victory is going to come once people
realize that it's all a bunch of crap
and all of this Authority and nonsense
is illegitimate at its core did you ever
comply because you you mentioned you
never complied I didn't have to because
I was working at compound media I had my
my so I was classified as a whatever
important worker whatever essential
worker and I didn't do the lockdown for
one minute yeah I did the two weeks and
then I feel like an idiot for it I mean
change is gonna happen when people take
personal responsibility for themselves
when they State start taking their
it's just hard because it keeps locking
my face here but when people start
taking their own lives into their own
hands and start making decisions for
their families for their communities for
their neighborhoods on a local level
that's when things will change
dramatically and they can change the
whole system the whole system is based
on another can I just say one thing
yeah once that lie is eviscerated then
and only then do the establishment
losers all power and the people actually
do stand up and actually do make a big
key Difference by just asserting
themselves as free Sovereign human
beings and here's the model the model is
gun right laws if you're if you're
looking at Washington it's going to be a
wash there if you go to the Wikipedia
and look at the gun right laws in
America page there is a gif that goes
year by year in terms of just like last
week where it goes from no one has gun
licenses to May issue to shall issue to
not even having a license and then state
by state it overwhelmingly changed Alex
let me please let me finish you've been
talking to any really you said 10
minutes Alex this is the gift a lot of
those middle states exactly and the
other thing is this is the model that's
going to happen what's going to save
America is when this happens with
regards to education as the money goes
to funding students instead of funding
systems and you get kids out of
government schools which are literal
prisons for children and the only place
many people experience about their
lifetimes the cathedral is ruined
because all you need is 10 of the
population to realize that this is all a
lie just look at this map and watches
all of these shall issues turn green
which is constitutional carry
unrestricted right to bear arms can you
explain what the colors are might be
hard to read so this is by so it's going
to start over in a second in 1986 no
issue meaning these states all the
states that are in red which is a large
amount will not give you concealed carry
in the yellow ones they might the blue
ones as they're now expanding are are
ordered they must give you a concealed
carry if you apply you can see here this
is I think that is Vermont right that's
an unrestricted Alaska unrestricted now
star starting around the mid-2000s the
late 2000s we start seeing the rise okay
2010 constitutional carry starts states
are now enforced enacting laws that say
you don't need a permit you don't need
to apply the Constitution says you have
a right to keep in bear arms Texas just
got this this is crazy Texas actually
you take a license an exam and a handgun
license now in Texas it's constitutional
carry freedom is is winning a chain
reaction yeah it could be a coincidence
that a bunch of those red states in the
middle are now green a bunch of the no
issues are now unrestricted that's crazy
Southern States said we will not give
you a concealed carry permit now they're
like you can what you can do whatever
you want we're not gonna ask you freedom
is contagious it should also I think the
chart is also going to be the same way
when it comes to homeschooling because
we're seeing yes huge rise of people
saying this indoctrination Center this
Rockefeller created education center is
something that's destroying my child's
flame my child's life is being destroyed
by this indoctrination by this hate and
by the way Luke in the beginning by the
way Luke it's almost over the top like
they're trying to cause a populist
Uprising yes everything they're like
what is it's so ridiculous and here's
the thing Alex it doesn't matter where a
parent stands politically you go on Tick
Tock and you see these uh educational
professors running professionals running
their mouths you're gonna think I don't
know what this is but I don't want this
person near my kid yeah there's a
universe that he professed
he was making excuses for pedophilia as
a as a university professor in sociology
making a video publicly not afraid to
say hey pedophiles are just you know
minor attracted persons no they're not
they're they're pedophiles they need to
be called out for what they are and and
trying to normalize this culturally is
having a huge backlash and they've been
doing this in Loudoun County but they've
been doing this in counties all
throughout the United States
I just want to point something out I
think it should be apparent to people
why we uh on our show are less likely to
get sensored a lot of people are just
like I don't understand how you know
we're like Tim isn't getting Shadow
banned as often we sometimes do and
they're like my show gets taken down and
I said these things and it's like
you know sometimes we have guests on the
show who just yell child rape out
normally we don't do them we tell people
like be careful because the idea is
what's important not the language and
and it's true that we have people who
watch with their kids and they ask us
not to do that so today's episode was
off the rails with all the swag and
everything uh it started when I got an
email and someone was like Hey I drive
in the Cardinals in your podcast if you
were more family friendly you know it'd
be more palatable I'm like oh that makes
sense but then we get a lot of people
and it's very obvious how I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna come out right right and
say it y'all are abrasive very abrasive
and very hard for regular people to get
into when you scream these extreme
things that people don't get when Joe
told you that you have the the I guess
what did he say it's like you you know
stuff so when you come out and say it
and people don't know it it comes like
you're by you're you're sort of blinded
by what you know and what people don't
so when when we're talking about stuff
and I think this comes from you know I
had I'd worked in non-profits and
marketing and fundraising if you want
someone to like have a conference
station and engage and you want to make
sure the ideas persist and they
understand
yelling something like child rape is a
guaranteed way to make sure they shut
down don't listen Okay Jim did I just
say something you're right that I can be
slicker
I was saying it's in the news today all
over the news I'm gonna try to be
credited I know I love you so I
understand you're right help me you're
right I can teach you you can teach me I
I agree I should have said it very
calmly and nicely
in Loudoun County the the young man that
raped the woman or allegedly ripped
woman has now pled guilty and so it
turns out no he didn't well he played no
contest okay you played no contest is a
no-fault uh um submission to the court
basically saying I'm not going to I'm
not contesting this just just do
whatever I defer to you the headline I
saw was is that he played uh uh
yeah so no contest is basically saying I
don't want to plead guilty because then
people will will be like aha you're
guilty I just don't think I can win if I
fall okay so my understanding is that
Nola contendori is regarded legally as
effectively a guilty plea all right
that's my understanding can someone look
it up on Wikipedia yeah you're like bag
you say I'm guilty but don't hit me it's
like if you get but all I'm saying is
this all I'm saying is this they said
that dad was a bad guy they said he was
a liar the New York Times said he made
it up and all I'm saying is is that that
is now in the news that that happened
and I and I'm sure you're right I'm not
perfect but everybody's big and tough
people should be able to hear this stuff
for sure sure I remember a long time ago
I was watching I think it was CNN I'm
not sure it might have been C-SPAN and
they were out on the ground and I can't
remember they were on the ground at some
event and you were there and they said
oh look it's you know it's it's uh Alex
Jones radio host and you came onto the
camera and immediately started going
people you gotta listen to me I'm
telling you right now and my friends
were just sorry they all started busting
out laughing and then they walked away
they turned it off Tim you were right
let me read it for no contest and
support legal issue yeah so when you
plead no contest like Spiro Agnew did I
believe the former vice president it's a
plea in which the defendant in a
criminal prosecution accepts conviction
as though a guilty plea has been entered
but does not admit guilt yeah and that
can work in Civil Court apparently
the point is the media said that Dad
made it up and arrested him and the dad
was pissed the the dude all right the
dude who was supposedly a woman went to
the next place I don't care if he's a
man or a woman I don't care what he did
he had reportedly assaulted a woman
that's why I'm upset you know 15 girls
this uh yeah this kid and and one of the
big things about it was they they
initially said that it was a trans team
but it wasn't
um which is the weirdest thing the the
the teen who pled no contest is not
trans as far as I know yeah and I don't
hate anybody gay straight whatever my
well that's the point too is just taking
advantage of the laws it's not exactly
the recovering perverts take advantage
but but no I I nobody it was a weird
thing so I read the story and I don't
think the the the the the the
perpetrator even claimed to be trans
someone just decided to say it to cover
up was he wearing a wig did he drive
wear a dress wearing a skirt wearing a
skirt and went into the girl's bathroom
to assault a girl so that just sounds
like a predator going to a bathroom to
assault somebody you know but but but
for both all you for everybody what's
the question why did they decide to not
just burn the person that did it instead
of trying to cover it up because it came
out in emails the school's like let's
cover this up because once it was a
narrative that it was a trans person
then they had the incentive to protect
their ideology and they're not going to
admit the district also had a policy
that they were gonna present and punch
in I think for the unisex bathrooms and
the teachers were going to be required
to address the students based off their
own preferred pronouns so they literally
shoved this girl under the rug that was
violated for the sake of a policy
because they didn't want it to come out
that this might be a bad idea it's a
cult
honestly I think this is what we're
talking about why things are changing I
mean I don't think anybody's politics is
really gonna
like control how people view their
children and what I mean by that is your
children are everything to you and if we
can't get behind protecting children and
we put politics and policy over children
I think we have some serious problems
this is why things are messaging and
Loudoun County assaulted and they're
also insulting people they literally
said the reason why Democrats lost in LA
in in this state was because it was a
white lash this was the narrative
they're insulting all these people when
if it was a white lash please tell me
how the first black Republican
lieutenant governor got elected
it's nothing to do with the laws nothing
to do with it's nothing to do with law
it's nothing to do with policy none of
that matters what matters is culture now
they will use school boards they will
use positions of power to enforce things
they want but if the culture does not
agree it does not happen the problem is
it says Michael described it most people
prefer safety over freedom them yep yep
so what happens is they don't get Saints
of the slavery they don't so here's what
happens culturally we almost exclusively
agree As Americans critical race Theory
when you actually discuss the tenets of
it what it actually is you go to someone
and say should we segregate people in
schools almost every single person 99
will say no then you ask them would you
be willing to go to a meeting and demand
they stop doing it and they'll say
absolutely not because I'm scared and
then what happens their kids get
segregated no you said it we've been
bullied and because we won't go that's
it so what do we do Tim I mean because
well I was saying uh in the primaries uh
primary out the establishing Republicans
like a Red Wave is not going to save
anybody but the free state project in
New Hampshire how do you feel about that
Michael I feel like that's a Libertarian
way of taking over the Republicans is
beautiful Or democrats right I don't
care how about we have a populist wave
take over everything yeah well like with
the free state project last time I
brought it up to malice I was like hey
are you going to pork fest you're like
no I'm like how dare you I think we're
going I think we're taking this RV pork
fest yeah if we can get Starling I we
can and I'll get it and and don't worry
about it that wasn't a knock against the
free state project that was a knock
against me being in the woods
okay okay I just want to clarify that
I'm a big fan of the Free State projects
we're going shooting Saturday come on
yes we're getting we're getting vaccines
different kind of shooting and we're
gonna bring barbecue down right are we
bringing barbecue did I get your
barbecue today you did from Terry black
I haven't had it yet it's amazing Blair
are you gonna bring your pink AR I can
do that yeah she's got one I got a
barbecue for you uh I want to go to the
woods with you though because I asked
Thursday too and everything I know it's
still we're gonna get it we're going to
go down and we want Rudy's we'll get
that
so you think like a Statewide
um school choice initiative is where the
net is the next step of God sounds good
I think I think we need a national free
state kind of thing yes we need people
at the local level to start voting only
for their local candidates who agree
with certain principles of Freedom
Liberty individual responsibility I
agree we need a litmus test for liberals
conservatives gay straight whatever do
you support the Bill of Rights the
Constitution everybody's rights let's
get past yeah who's going to be put this
is nonsense who's going to be putting
this litmus test into practice they do
it if they do it in New Hampshire New
Hampshire has the highest amount of
homeschoolers per capita than the entire
the United States they have some of the
highest IQ they have this they have some
of them
you're full of [ __ ] because you saw what
happened with the lockdowns if they all
wanted Freedom we wouldn't have the
lockdown that's a complete lie stop the
lockdowns
yeah wait no why are you so pessimistic
I'm not pessimistic because I'm thinking
if you think the Salvation is going to
be voting in the right people you're
completely devotional culturally fight
at everything level Alex voting is one
aspect Alex he's talking about the
Lemmings the millions of lemmings in
this country that bend the knee into the
globally and to the Constitution what do
we do about them and they don't want
freedom you have to create systems that
work around them
which means non-democratic systems yeah
I think what does that mean
non-democratic meaning systems that
don't depend on getting majority of
simpletons to agree with you no I agree
if I'm a Republican
in the Republicans you have 51 percent
want to enslave me they don't have it
right but if it's 85 it doesn't matter I
don't care how many people how popular
it is my rights are not up for
discussion let alone a vote and Luke the
reason I was disagreeing with you is so
mad I am mad because there's a war in
our minds what I was disagree with you
about Luke is New Hampshire is a
self-sucking population it's a very
small population you can't replicate the
free state project on a nationwide level
because there's a huge percent of the
population as you agree with who does
not view do not share our values I
disagree because if you look at just
autonomy I don't care if it's a bunch of
Communists wanting to live in the woods
we have examples of this with the Amish
the Amish are living by their own set of
rules without government they're not
mandates we're not vaccine mandates and
they're and they're doing a lot better
than a lot of other people so if the
Amish that's not true no no they are
dealing with but there haven't had a
significant Cheryl uh Atkinson's did a
great documentary about this yeah it's
on our YouTube channel it's great they
are dealing with covet uh you guys are
both right and I think you're right but
but they don't have a huge death rate
like many people expected to even though
they have policies where they literally
drink from the same cup they have
religious ceremonies where and everyone
said the Amish are going to die the
Amish are going to have a huge
Extinction event that didn't happen
their death rate has stayed the same
with covid comparatively to the rest of
the population so that's a big thing
Cheryl Atkinson's documentary is really
huge here and if the Amish could do it
the free state project could do it and
that's victory in itself that's Victory
when people say hey I just want to have
my own kind of life my own rules my own
autonomy
non-compliances and New Hampshire it has
created a beacon for Bitcoin has created
a beacon for personal responsibility for
personal freedom from homeschooling it's
becoming in The Shining Light an example
of people coming together and saying hey
this is how I want to live you can live
there and if people want to be communist
let them go to New York let them go to
Los Angeles they have a right to live
wherever that's what I'm saying it's not
gonna replicate Nationwide it doesn't
have to be certain I have an
administrative thing to say I have an
administrative of thing to announce to
the people listening um for the super
chats at a certain point YouTube just
touched the leading super chats so we we
can read some of them but uh I just I
just want to say next I feel bad for a
lot of people who are you know posting
comments and questions
when you have a show this big we had 110
plus I think like 114 or 15 000 people
walking in one more time yeah YouTube
just basically starts erasing the super
chats thank you everyone give me a copy
of those shots
you could live in New York City you
could live in Los Angeles or you could
live in New Hampshire I live in New
Hampshire because that's why I choose
Luke I moved to Austin for this reason
uh you're preaching to the choirnia but
you moved to the new comedy foreign
the point is you were Tim and Alex were
asking how do we replicate this
Nationwide and all I'm saying is you
can't replicate the free state project
Nationwide because there's not enough
people to make that happen
democratically no I disagree
um we were just talking about how uh was
it so who was mentioning this the
primaries basically dictate how all the
elections are being run okay are we
talking about this I don't think we were
but the idea is that you get a small a
small amount of people who will vote for
a Democrat and then Mo uh Independence
basically don't like they don't
participate in primary so they they
enter the election and they're like what
are my choices whatever the Democrat 10
and the Republican 10 percent voted for
what happens if you get a free state
project of you got to stay with a
million people or you got you got a
jurisdiction of a million people and a
hundred thousand are liberty-minded
people who are brought together sure and
they all say we are all going to vote in
the Republican primary for this
libertarian and then the independent
moderates have no choice vote that takes
over that's a trump one I mean it's how
the progressive it's how AOC one yeah
nobody actually knows what who or what
she was I feel like I'm crazy there's an
enormous asymmetry because when you have
those two candidates whoever that
libertarian candidate is will be
demonized by the corporate press that
backfires now what Biden won
by fraud yeah I think you're right that
we need a non-democratic solution Steve
Bannon the the this is I'll tell you
what the most okay well he would win
right now I don't think he'd win right
now but the most frustrating thing they
won two seats in Georgia they write an
article explaining about the shadow
campaign to save the election they talk
about mail-in voting and how it gave
them massive advantages over Republicans
and then you end up with this large
populace movement spinning in circles
about things they haven't proven in a
year and then instead of getting their
ground game going and countering the
changes to election law they're going
around screaming at each other about
Tim's right engaged him in a reset War
I'm trying to get people to realize is
there a website for that Alex the
corporation is creating
recentwars.com the point is it's the
biggest thing I'm doing it's going to
launch next month or two years but what
sure I've changed the world a lot here
so I'm not a BS or this is Big Stuff how
do we get people aware of the global
corporate structure how they're mind
controlling us instead of just receiving
the propaganda we've got a big awakened
population right now how do we get them
engaged I would say build a
decentralized parallel system and I'll
give it to you also well I'll say I'll
say it's do do ridiculous things like
this yes you know I was like Hey we're
gonna do a really really crazy show
navigate the minefields the best of your
abilities so they don't you know chop
the tree down before it's a chance to
bear fruit and I will say
um free state-like ideas it's not
perfect but I think New Hampshire is
doing something something very very
powerful and positive and I gotta tell
you if we're gonna if we're gonna have
any victories like what New Hampshire is
doing is very interesting and it can be
done in other states a small minor a
small minority of politically active
individuals can over like look at the
mises caucus I know the libertarian
parties when Dave Smith gets 15 of the
Democrat of the of the polling numbers
in 2024 and I'm the press secretary for
that campaign getting 15 of polls is not
impossible and then things are really
good and then what happens is you may be
in the minority but most people will
just vote for one or the other and if
you're the alternative to the corrupt
machine where the red people are ready
to vote for a ham sandwich you're there
so here's what I want to say so right
now one of the things that bothers me
the most we had Steve Bannon on this
show and I think he's a very smart guy
and we we did a members only segment
where we talked about fraud and he's
adamant in his belief and I said take a
look at Universal mail-in voting take a
look this is why I believe there is no
fraud and I believe it's a red herring
that has manipulated the populists into
totally losing their standing and
grounding and their ability to to win
these these battles because you have in
a Democrat City one look at New York you
get one housing complex with 500 units
they all get five Universal mail-in
bouts for the five people who live their
mom dad and they're 2.5 kids the
Democrat sends one activist to go door
to door and hits 500 families times five
votes each and they can do that in a
couple days just knocking on doors if
they make their web and they say this
did you vote yet your ballot is right
there fill it out I'll wait repub
Republicans have to go to rural areas
where they drive through suburbs and
they can hit five houses on one block
and they can get 10 houses in a day
Republicans should focus on cities
Republicans should focus on the rule
changes that heavily Advantage urban
dance centers the Republicans should
focus on the rule changes that
disadvantaged Republicans instead what
are we getting Trump's movement the
populists are right now they're talking
about
Venezuela and China and gun battles in
Germany and I'm like they shut them down
with the conspiracy fraud stuff and now
because Donald Trump won in 2016 with 77
000 votes across three states sure he
did really well in the Electoral College
but it was 77 000 votes across three
states and so they said if we can throw
the populist movement off base with
something that won't have an impact on
us we won't lose again and they did it a
year before the 2020 election the
Republicans in Pennsylvania changed the
law to introduce Universal mail-in
voting we talked with Sean Parnell about
this he's sued about this they said at
first we're going to create Universal
mail-in voting uh-oh our Constitution
forbids it and they stopped because they
needed the Constitutional amendment to
enact it they stopped and said okay what
do we do let's change the word to mail
it instead of absentee and pass it
anyway and when Sean when Sean Parnell
and others sued over this because it was
an unconstitutional change a lower court
judge said on the merits you will likely
win it went to a higher Court who said
for for not on the merits just for
standing or for it's too late I found
the the the the the the Latin word for
two letters they said we're not even
gonna take the case so we see an article
that in Time Magazine the shadow
campaign to win to save the election and
they explain exactly what they did we
changed all the rules to heavily
advantaged dense Urban centers and then
Republicans got not Republicans but the
populace got wrapped up in a fraud
narrative that stopped them from there's
a whole book about this there's a whole
book about something let me say one
sentence one sense there's a whole book
about this called rig by Molly Hemingway
I know you had a mark on the show right
to discuss this so people are interested
they can read about it go ahead Alex no
I'm just gonna say where does this all
end we're about to be at war with China
the Dollar's plunging there's massive
inflation let's talk about the big
picture what is the American people
going to do as they realize that the
design collapses here and that all these
corporate interests think we're too
stupid to understand what's happening to
me that's the big deal forget Trump
forget Democrats forget you know all
this stuff we are in a major sea change
right now I love you Alex I think being
happy healthy and prepared for whatever
comes next is the solution is the real
resistance yes and there's going to be a
lot of turmoil especially economically
hitting this country as soon as covet
happened I was like this is not going to
be about covet this is going to be about
the economy and we're seeing the the
start of this this is only the beginning
of this and I think we're really headed
for hard times and I think the way to
resist this is by having family is by
having a network is by having a cohesive
group together that is ready for
whatever happens if you're unprepared
you're weighing down your family you're
weighing down your neighborhood you're
weighing down your community so right
now more than ever smarten up look at
the situation that's happening in front
of you and make sure that you are ready
for whatever's to come because it's
going to go it's going to be a very
bumpy ride I totally agree with that we
should just transcend all the arguments
and realize this is a global engineer
collapse yes it is I'm concerned about
the food supply I think because people
love each other until they get hungry
you're looking pretty good right we need
to fix the shipping industry because
right now Amazon's got kind of uh Alex
you'll be the first one we eat let's
face it how do you how do you bring
about the equity they have said they
want to bring about it's simple knock
everyone to zero and then there's no
systemic inequality and everyone is now
destitute and poor and then when you
start over everyone will be the same or
so they believe we'll see no I agree if
you wanted to run an actual communist
system you'd knock everyone to zero and
then let their own instincts bring it
back up but they're not going to do that
we'll see what would happen is there are
some people of skill and Merit who will
naturally rise to the top and there are
some people who won't and so there's
this belief among among the
postmodernists of blank Slaters and all
that stuff that you knock everyone you
strip every one of what they own take
away everything they own and make them
all worth nothing and then when they
start over everyone will be equal but
you know what's going to happen uh oh
The Tall Grass will start growing again
and as you as we know the Communists
will decide you have to cut the tall
grass and they'll keep they'll keep
having to mow the lawn to deal with the
fact that some people are better than
others and I don't mean like
I I mean quite literally in terms of
skill in terms of yeah it's okay it's
okay that some people are better than
others at work
it's okay literally Sports math science
yeah there's a lot of folks better at
lifting weights or doing math to me I've
got my skills it was a better fighter
than I am he's a badass I need to
recognize that he's better than being
fighting
that's right and so what happens when
you have a society of a bunch of people
and some people are just better than
others and then you learn oh I'm better
at this let me provide this to the man
or woman that's better than me at this
and then we have a symbiotic
relationship and that's what it's all
about so so what ends up happening then
is the guy who's better than you know
Michael at baking cakes makes the cakes
because why would Michael if someone
else can do it better yeah and then all
of a sudden we have Society with really
awesome cake we have great basketball
players we have great scientists we have
um amazing and talented politicians who
clearly no I'm kidding about that last
one but uh uh then people can say you
know whoever is really good at this task
can help provide that task that's
basically what we do
the the post-modernist neo-marxist
Communist whatever this ideology this
cult religion they don't believe that
exists so what will happen well they'll
have to purge anyone who proves it
doesn't exist yeah they want to they
want to attack anybody does it fit of
that model but then that's the LIE they
say they're in charge in the model they
say oh nobody's in charge but them right
and if they're not say there's like a
horrible reset where like an asteroid
hit the earth and wiped out the
population they can't grew back like 13
000 years ago you see Warlords you see
the people that are the best at and got
there first taking power not necessarily
good
um
it's an it's never been a perfect system
it's an imperfect system tyranny is not
a conspiracy theory and I think people
need to understand that you know you're
either going to learn through wisdom or
you're going to learn through a learn
through experience and I mean we could
sit here and warn the world with
absolute truth day in day out every
single night giving them the best
coherent arguments as to why they
shouldn't follow these dangerous
ideologies but it's not until they
actually feel it experience it well they
actually wake up and I'm not talking
about the people that are watching that
are awake to this stuff I'm talking
about the people that actually believe
what's being told to them on CNN and all
these properties that's beautiful
tyranny is not a conspiracy it's not a
conspiracy theory it's happened in human
history and I just want I want to
communicate to the viewers right now we
are not telling you what to think we are
telling you think for yourself because
if you're not thinking for yourself then
someone else is thinking for you whether
it's left or right and that's when you
get into a dangerous place that's
happening in mainstream media that's
happening in the music industry that's
happening in education it's happening on
all fronts and right now this podcast
Justice for the purpose to communicate
to the public think for yourself because
that is the message that I think every
single one of us that's right don't give
your will over to anybody and two things
hopefully whatever ends up happening to
this podcast had already reached a lot
of people yeah what is it Millions
already I think we probably uh in total
views maybe over a million but I won't
know until we rap when we get the full
number you had Joe Rogan for an hour I'm
grateful man uh what was the peak live
number one no I think it was a little
bit more than one thing you told me when
I was almost a record
no no no when you were when we had you
on last year's like 140. that was us
yeah yeah it was crazy
but uh uh uh so the other thing I'll say
is I'm I'm only gonna take I'm not sure
I'm gonna try and take a few super chats
we should let's just welcome
I'm looking for the hard legitimate good
questions right that we can that can
spark the conversation but I I greatly
respect and appreciate all the super
chats that are saying you know fjb and
we love the show and things like that I
mean it I mean it YouTube deleted a lot
of them but I want to try and find the
core uh questions that we can ask to
kind of you know keep this conversation
at a good level we have one right here
from Hoosier films is malice how do we
go from the Constitution is garbage and
Boomer to the to the freedom will come
through gun rights laws how exactly will
those get done legally without current
2A uh the 2A has been a very very poor
bulwark against government encroachment
against gun rights as the fact is that
as a New Yorker it's almost impossible
to get a handgun so this the second
minute is supposed to codify your right
to bear arms but the courts can Define
it however they like and they completely
dismiss it so the best answer for gun
rights is gun proliferation because once
there's enough guns distributed through
the population it's literally impossible
to have that uh Bell be unrung power to
the people what about like arms in
general like if you had like Nano Bots
that could fly into people's ears and
blow their heads like would should
everyone have that weapon too no only me
right yeah and Blair like this would 2A
cover that but that's the big question
the globalists said they're gonna take
over and have world government to stop
proliferation of Vader technology which
I get but then they still have the power
of course yes it never applies to them
but that's the part of everything that
came out of 2020 that didn't work in
their favor was there were so many
people who realized for the first time
in their lives they needed a gun and one
more thing everyone's stupid Facebook
friend for a long time up till 2020 was
talking about a look at Australia they
gave up their guns and now they don't
have crime you're full of it look at
Australia and now I'm gonna say tell
your Facebook friends yeah look at
Australia yeah look at that look at gun
control it equals total slavery look at
Europe they have the most vaccine
the least amount of gun ownership yeah
no small country references so uh I'll
say it again like most of super chats
are just like I agree or great show and
things like that and thank you all so
much for the super chats this is a huge
show for us but we have we have a good
question here Uncle Sam says Tim do you
still stick to it's just a mask why or
why not I saw it as a cracked door to
what we are experiencing now thoughts I
I do feel like it's just a mask for the
most part we we flew out here and they
said you have to wear a mask by federal
law I said what federal law and they
were like there is none and then I was
like I don't wear the mask I'm not
stressed about it right there's no
federal law mandating The Masks but if a
private business says we're gonna have
we have a plan you can fly it you gotta
wear a mask I say okay it's like
whatever it was it was three hours it's
annoying I don't like it but it's not
irreversible a private company it's it's
tough right it go to
minimallycompletymaths.com and you get a
mess that doesn't do anything but it
looks like it's doing something well
regardless of that that's what I use I I
think I do we had Converse we had a
conversation recently we had a
conversation on the show
um the CDC has like they've put out 65
studies saying masks do reduce
transmission to varying degrees and the
numbers vary wildly depending on what
people think the efficacy is but
ultimately there's a challenge of
private businesses can say we want you
to wear a mask the same as they say we
want you to wear a shirt and it's not
the end of the world for me to walk into
a store put on a mask walk off take it
walk out take it off it is however when
the business says you can't enter unless
you undergo an irreversible medical
procedure that's very very different
medical IDs and the vaccine passport is
the key to the carbon tax and the social
credit score the the vaccine pass in the
Davos group's own words is the platform
and the key to their entire takeover
yeah digital ID everywhere you go they
walk in the papers no matter what
exactly they could track and Trace you
and then they get a social credit score
here's a very very important question
um Maddie Matt Matt says Tim who's the
smoking hot babe with the sultry voice
sitting next to Blair Michael Mouse
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
there are a lot of really funny joke
questions that I would love to read but
I really am trying to find them all no I
want to find like the good questions
about like what's going on and what we
can answer what we can talk about that's
actually you know spark a conversation
um well a lot of people are asking Blair
to do something with Tom McDonald and
considering there were many of those
I've seen so far I did a whole music
video what else do they want I mean I
guess more I guess
oh man trying to find good I'd love to
but
I was on Blair's show reacting to Tic
Tac so you could find that yeah everyone
should go watch the video we just posted
the UFOs talk about Tic Tacs with all
these crazy people I want Alex on my
channel I've seen it
oh Jesus
the first show I ever went on was
actually Alex's show I think I had like
10 000 subscribers and I had the nice
back when YouTube messaging was a thing
there was inboxes you sent me the nicest
message I forget exactly what you said
but it was just very nice and you were
the first show I was ever on so uh this
is not it there's not a question but
it's a statement but I think it's it's
still a good one uh Asher Litwin says to
answer Blair's comment about prop police
cars they're often used as a deterrent
in lieu of an actual officer oh wow
that's smart interesting all I know is I
know a guy who does that and he said
well they got burned up or something
well they all got yeah they'll buy my
house they got one that has like a a
clock on it saying how fast you're going
interesting so I gotta be honest
not a whole lot of good direct you know
thanks for your money
I can read uh Chase says share this link
like And subscribe yes please do but no
no but not not all of like I'm trying to
find the questions where it's like you
said yeah
what is the secret of the universe
there's you know here's I'm not trying
to I'm not trying to not read people
super chats but you know a lot of them
are like thank you great great job doing
the show you know I came in late great a
great show things like that and so I
really really respect that and I
appreciate it
um but I'm I'm going through just
looking forward
to find a good one I just want to thank
Tim for setting this up this is
incredible uh I seriously can't thank
you enough I think this was one of the
most epic podcasts ever and I just want
to thank you
no you got to do the return the map
return the
sincerely thank you Tim for uh setting
this up this is absolutely incredible
yes
Admiral Nelson says this episode lived
up to the hype thanks for the show Tim
yeah
have these type of conversations all the
time feel free to stop by give us some
real house questions why did the Bible
remove all the psychedelics Kyle that
Jesus did from it
it was for Rogan but Rowan's not here
but I still think we can discuss it Kyle
Petty says Tim please ask Rogan what
it's like being the being the new Target
for all mainstream media even the new
Netflix special inside job insinuates
he's a flat earther and says YouTube and
Joe Rogan are lying to you don't know if
he knows about that now Joe's not here
because he had to leave but did you see
the SNL parody of it it was not even
jokes
it's good to be attacked by a dying
system it is a big town of success
Netflix created a show called Inside Job
Luke talked about it I'll say this I was
I was hooked on that show like I had to
watch it and it was not funny it was not
it was supposed to be fun it was a
comedy show comedy and you'd see the
Beats for the jokes that didn't work but
there was one joke I chuckled at where a
psychic mushroom from the hollow Earth
was talking about how he can't hang out
with Joe Rogan anymore and and like just
it was it's too far we've gone no it was
funny I can't remember what the joke was
but he was just like mushrooms everybody
know you're on Joe show tomorrow yeah
and this is the hard thing because
that's why Joe was like hey I'll see you
tomorrow like I'm gonna go on uh Joe's
show and I'm I'm like sweating bullets
because I'm like if the verdict comes in
and I'm on his show and we're doing like
this not so I'm we're here in this in
the mobile Studio I've got news I got
this I got the the verdict that the
trial playing in real time I'm sitting
here doing my work because I'm like
wired into the Matrix Gotta Dance with
Uber you're gonna do a show oh no of
course of course I'm just saying I'll be
on this show constantly wondering what
is it like I'm gonna I'm gonna walk out
of the cave and look at the sun you see
my phone what you're taping tomorrow at
like noon yeah I will I swear to God
I'll text you the murder comes in all
right well
like somehow you won't be able to learn
otherwise no no no
no no friend yeah and I'm gonna be
watching live covering it and and then I
will text him if it happens okay that
way he can focus on Joe I'm on air
focusing I will let him know teamwork
let's take something you an anarchist
don't get something communist Mal say
tongue baby
Stalin being independent whole part and
finding information on their own Let's
uh we'll take this question this is a
good one because it's based on what
we're saying
um mad is that was it Mad Anthony Matt
Anthony says Tim what do you feel what
do you feel about the judge in The
Rittenhouse case overturning the jury if
they find him guilty and uh uh yeah
we'll put we'll leave it there
um
yes I agree with that I think that there
should already be a mistrial with
prejudice oh yeah because the state
committed a grave constitutional
violation the judge even called out but
the judge is worried questioning his
fifth amendment is wrong yes yes and on
the stand in front of the jury yeah and
and that wasn't the only thing he
admitted evidence in to the jury that
wasn't supposed to be admitted NES
Witnesses the lie and he admitted CGI
evidence at this point I feel like the
left is like the judge's bias and he
needs to beat this barn or whatever it
is removed from the and I'm like he's
biased for them and they don't even
realize it because they're so insanely
biased the judge is done a fairly good
job across the board dismissing the gun
charges were like that guy can I say I
had Robert Barnes again he's got my show
you're welcome this week and we had an
hour of him breaking down the case and
and he really went to detail because I
hadn't been following the case and he
really educated me it was fascinating
one of the most reset wars.com was
resetwars.com
resetwars.com what's the name of the kid
who sued CNN and Nicholas
I asked Robert about that and it's very
very hard to prove damages because if
your damages are a trial it's not the
same as like I lost a job or I got
defamed so it's that's actually not a
likely unless shows then you get a
default they would have to prove malice
like uh malicious
in order to approve malice the state is
allowed to prosecute you in good faith
and they they owe you nothing if you are
found you're not guilty but if it's
malicious prosecution which this may be
then you consume that's almost never
found though right it's almost
impossible right this is definitely
malicious prosecution because you have
all the videos and they know they try to
misrepresent
all right let's uh we'll we'll do a
couple more uh sexual Satchel Gizmo says
and Luke can get this one in an
anarcho-capitalist Society how do you
prevent corporations from monopolizing
military power and creating a pseudo
government
good question I want to give it to you I
think they have no answer
markets do not tend toward Monopoly
number one uh number two is there's no
look at NATO there's no reason
militaries do what you can argue and say
markets don't but militaries take over
markets I like the cartels not
monopolies sure the point being the
cartels are governments exactly that's
another okay well how did the Mexicans
are arguing semantics the point being
that the every what it present is the
strongest arguments against anarchism or
inevitably descriptions status quo right
so if your concern is that what we have
what we have now then it's a wash my
point being when you have
decentralization and you have
competition especially in the military
context you would have these Roman
coalitions where sometimes you'd have
the NATO thing sometimes you have like
the Iraq War and so on and so forth
there's no reason for it to be
systematized into a monopoly because
monopolies are inherently inefficient
and a function of government and overall
there will be less harm when things are
more decentralized rather than no I
agree with their nuclear missiles that
are literally above our heads and
satellites waiting to come down
as he's carrying a nuclear football
everywhere he goes that to me is
dangerous did you say nuclear nuclear uh
football
a little bit yeah I agree with you but
but the thing is it's not how do you
decentralize things without giving the
decentralizer's power yeah right like
random what language are you speaking
well like random dude and his nine
buddies will have a nuclear warhead at
that point
Greek economics power only becomes
centralized as a function of government
look at the music industry look at
literature look at podcasts in the news
markets tend towards competition and
choice as opposed to work
tending towards monopolies because
that's that's what stops me from Anarchy
all the way I'm like a monarchist I
guess we've I've got some bad news the
bad news is actually good news um you
mentioned I'm going on Joe's show
tomorrow and that means in order to get
my work done I gotta wake up at 5 00 a.m
so I want it I want to unleash
the members only show and be able to
just go off the rail so my friends all
of all of you who are listening go to
timcast.com become a member this is our
insulated protective sphere of warmth
where we can say literally whatever we
want and swear all day and you've given
them a badass show with Joe Rogan on
this great crew this is yeah Alex Jones
ladies
communist leader Michael Allen it shows
it the show is not over what we what we
do every every night is after the main
show live and there and and let's be
real like we got we we do we are careful
about you know sometimes what you do to
reset Wars but you go to go to
timcast.com become a member and we're
gonna have a members only segment of
this very show where we're going to
continue the show on our website and
Michael miles is going to strip tease
and yes yes I guess so I guess so so uh
it'll be like that Patrick Swayze uh
exciting life sketch with Chippendale
how are you going to give me a powerful
slug on air when we come back
I'm not a strong person what you are
we're going shooting Saturday okay
I think Joe may come we're going
shooting Saturday I'll have barbecue out
of my Ranch am I going to be hunted for
sports no no
it is a safe environment it is yeah have
you ever shot before there's security
there's security inside is this
what we smell blood yes on my nose
misgendered that dog all right
go to timcast.com become a member and
help support us
um uh smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share the show if you
really like it you guys did thank you so
much for for an amazing show thanks so
much for tuning in you can follow it
again tell them how to tell them how to
subscribe timcast.com become a member
it's very very easy and then we have we
have a huge library of members only
shows where we just we talk crazy it's
crazy talk there's like a two-hour show
where Luke massages me with oil
fake news this information
yeah all right are we going around yes
we are but hold on follow the the show
at Tim cast IRL everywhere we have Clips
on Instagram you can follow me at
timcast on Instagram or whatever else at
resetwars.com biggest thing I've done
yet it launches in three weeks in the
middle of December resetwars.com it's
the next slope we got the MK Ultra
what's the website reset Wars what is it
all right all right I got to be up at
five a.m
Sam that sounds like a you problem
um Blair White on YouTube Twitter and
Instagram just search the name you can
watch me and Michael's new collab on my
channel it's really really funny and
yeah just search me on everything and
freeworldnews.tv come on Alex Leonard
Alice watch yourself I think reset Wars
is great branding nice one Alex is
coming on my channel Ian crossland.net
pass the buck
Drew yeah follow me on uh on Twitter
Drew H live go to my website
joachlive.com that's how you can support
me start oiling me yes
coconut oil if you want to know more
about the shirt that I'm wearing and how
Epstein and Christmas lights are
connected you can find out by going to
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and
supporting me there and I also have Luke
uncensored.com where I just launched all
my apocalypse survival training videos
all of it exclusively for members Luke
uncensored.com I hope to see you soon
that's right and thank you guys all very
much for tuning in oh let me throw it to
Michael before you before you did a
great job
war cry oh
my
mouse
okay whoa whoa whoa let Michael promote
his book yes I'm very very excited
anarchistownbook.com the audiobook has
finally gotten to a distributor Tim did
one of the chapters for the audiobook so
that's gonna be it Anderson that's a
sexy book yeah thank you so you get to
enter sandbook.com the books of me
anarchistaudiobook.com and you can
follow me on Michael malice and you can
smash my subscribe button at youtube.com
michaelmalisofficial where I also take
some by the way you need to return my
calling on my show promoted
all right we're gonna go thank you guys
very much for tuning in for this super
awesome and Austin show with Joe Rogan
you guys can follow me on Twitter at
sour patchlands we will we have more
followers kids now yes we will see all
of you at timcast.com in a members only
segment with this very show and we're
gonna just open the floodgates here
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
there everyone war cry right now ready
all right